Battery's dead. All right.
We're gonna go ahead and get started. We weren't stalling at all because
I know traffic is bad and some people had to drive a little ways,
but I'm sure we'll hear about that. So we'll go
ahead and call this work session to order. That's the work session of the Eagle
Mountain City Council, May 19th. It is officially 4:03,
and we'll get started with our first discussion item. If you need a
few minutes, I can go to the second one, but we had you first,
so. Okay, I'm gonna go come back to you. So we're
actually gonna go to item 1B, if that's okay, 'cause I know Benjamin's
ready to go. So if that's okay, we'll start. It's a discussion on becoming a
believer city. This is something that we've all been a part of
over time, and I, I think I've talked to you guys about this. I don't
really remember, but Ben's gonna present what it is, and we can give
staff direction or whatever it is that we wanna do. So.
Awesome. How are you today? It's good to see you.
I just wanted to take you back really quick to
about 7 years ago, just to set the stage.
So I had this note in my phone that I wrote down,
and I just wanted to read it to you really quick. It says,
I have a crazy idea. I'm going to run holding signs
to help lift other people as they drive by. I also want to
get others involved and grow it huge. The inspiration came over time,
but today it hit harder with specifics. I wanted to
write it down just in case I forgot. This was back on July 18th,
2019. So eventually I started. I don't know
if all of you know, Some of you do what I do.
I go around the city running with my sign. Everybody's nodding. Okay, good.
It's been such an amazing experience. I have had— I can't
even count anymore. I can't count the stories of the impact it's had on people
very early on, how it's changed people's
lives. But I knew I needed to share it.
And ever since I started doing it, I actually started in 2022. Wow.
Took me a while to get up the courage to do it,
but I knew I had to share it with people, and I wanted to get
other people involved. So what I've done this year— I've been
working for quite a while, but I've launched a nonprofit. It's called Show Me
a Sign, and the point of it is to invest belief at scale,
and to do that through every person and
every organization. And so you can join me as a believer. You can sign
up, and basically you There's a list of actions,
specific things that you do, and you can go and log those. Running is one
of them. You get points, kind of gamifies it. It's a fun thing. And I
have chapters, start chapters at schools and in the community. But really,
I also wanted to involve large organizations like the city.
And so at the city level, what's involved in that are
2 things. One is helping me bring
belief visible in the environment, number one,
and number two is in the people. So two would be the
chapters in the city, working with them to bring events
like, we have this event coming up next month, we did it last year,
the Motivation Mile. We're already doing some of those things as a city. But really
the key one I wanted to talk about today was that first one, was bringing
it into the environment, and how do you do that? And so what
I call that is my Road Signs of Belief initiative.
So at the city level, My nonprofit raises the money
for signs of belief, and then working with the city government
and city officials, getting permission, whether we
have to change policy, whether we have, you know, have to talk about those things,
but getting permission to install those around the city in key locations,
not all over the place, not spamming and making it
become something like wallpaper that you just ignore, but something really impactful.
Yeah. in key areas and having those signs just like the ones
that I hold when I run, but having them available 24/7.
People that are coming home from work late at night, a terrible job
situation, and they see that sign and it changes their day,
it changes their week. It inspires them to do something completely
different than they would have, to not road rage the people in front of them,
to not go on Eagle Mountain City Citizens and post rude
comments. Just think of the impact we
could have with some of these things. Everybody smiled when I said that. You don't
read that group, do you? No, it's a great group.
I love living here. I've lived here for 20 years this year. And so that
is my proposal to Eagle Mountain becoming
the first believer city and helping me do those 2 things,
bring belief into the environment and into the people.
So I don't know how this works. I don't usually come to this. We have
like a Q&A. Yeah, that's, that's perfect. I actually just
sent the website to Lacey to see if you put it on the screen.
Oh, okay, perfect. Yeah, because I just— to show that if
it's possible. If not, it's okay. One of the things that
you'd mentioned earlier was the schools have signed up as a school or
as a club. What I have pulled up is Become
a Believer City, and then it just says sign up now. It says
what is a Believer City, and then some of the activities
and mentions and stuff on the website. So the
question really is, does Eagle Mountain want to become a
Believer City on the website? And there's no cost.
So those are kind of the questions. Can I weigh in here, Mayor? I had
the opportunity to spend, gosh, I don't know, probably too long at Ben's house on
a Saturday or Friday afternoon. I invited you and
he's like, yes, I'll be there. And so we've discussed this in
some detail, and I think that— I
think number one, I want to say that I'm supportive of exploring this idea.
I think that— I think it would be a shame for another city
to become the first city to adopt or to embrace the
I Believe in You mantra that Ben has kind of created.
And so for me at least, I think it's something that we absolutely
should have a real discussion about as a council and and
decide, number one, is it something we should do? And I believe that it is.
So I'm going to say that I'm supportive of that. I think there may
be some challenges with it in some areas as to how do we
do that and how do we remain— I
just, in my mind's eye, there are some questions that I have that we need
to deal with, with legal and other things, right? How are we fair and equal
and even-handed with— other organizations who might have a
similar need or a similar desire to partner with the city. But I think it's
something that we should explore. And, uh, I've had the chance to look at
his website, kind of go through it. I just invite each of you to do
the same and become familiar with it. And I'd really like to see us take
this up in one of our very next off-site meetings and see if we
can't do something with that, and then find some time to support
what he's got going on on this. Is it the 6th of June, right?
Isn't that the date? Yep. Yeah. Yeah,
1:00 PM.
Okay. What's the website? It's showmeasign.org.
Yeah.
I guess my question is how we
apply what we do, I feel like can come later
in the mix. Where and if signs are going in a certain
place, all of those other things. But opting
to be a believer city, it feels
like a no-brainer to me, so I don't want to delay it at all.
I think it'd be best if we— if that's what we want to do,
that we move forward boldly and just take care of that, and then we can
figure out the rest and how we apply it
as a body.
Yeah, so if you click on Become a Believer,
Button there, and then we're a city or town.
So this page just goes through, it gives a kind of an overview,
kind of a pitch, right? This is what it means,
and this is why we need to do it, and then these are the benefits.
And then there's actually a guide at the bottom you can go through. There's an
audio overview at the top. So everything's here.
to walk you through. And I understand there's challenges,
right? I mean, you can't just have everybody going around putting signs, and you have
to make sure it's done in a way that's legal, that's safe. Again,
I wanted to reiterate, it's not something the city would pay for. I would raise
the money myself through my nonprofit. I would just need to
work with the administration side of it.
Can you scroll back up just where it shows that sign on the side of
the road? Oh, at the top?
Keep going. Right there. Is that an example
of the kind of signs you're looking to put? Yeah. So, okay. Yeah. So I
have something I put a lot of thought into. It's called the Language of
Belief. So there's another page on my site that
you can go to and see. Basically,
I feel really passionate about this. The best thing that I could say to you,
if I had one, if I had 2 seconds with you, right? The most
powerful thing I could say to you is I believe in you. I believe that's
the best thing I could say. If I tell you I loved you, you didn't
know me very well, right? It would be kind of weird. So I believe
that's the best type of language to use is, hey, I believe in your potential
to do something better. And so I believe in phrases that
are of that ilk, right? Of a belief base. And so I actually have a
whole list of phrases that I've rated. I have a scoring system and everything
that you can go look at on the page as well, Language of Belief.
But I would suggest that you look at those phrases
and choose the ones that are highly scored there because I've seen them have the
most impact. That was my next question. Yeah. I put a lot of thought into
it. There's a lot of signs you could put up. So, we can just take
a look at what the messages are. Yeah. Even the placement of where they are.
I think that would be great. I like this idea. I think it's There
is power in words, and sometimes, you know, nobody else can get through to a
person, and something as simple as seeing something like that sparks something in
you that allows you to take that
next step. I think that— I think it's a great idea.
I'd love to go through the number of
places that we're talking about putting them. I think key locations
would be great. I think this embodies What I
think Eagle Mountain is, what I've been trying to push forward
for the Eagle Mountain way, ways that we can show that we
care about our community, that we're here for each other, that we're neighbors
working together. I think this is a great way. I love that,
thank you. I keep trying to touch the screen, but it's a screen share.
I think just what you got on your shirt right there, I believe in you,
that's so recognizable. I don't know why you're
running Cory B. Ride. I was like, that guy's nuts. I'm very
visible and very safe. But I honked at you a couple times, and it is
cool. Like, you're on your way to work, you've had a crazy morning, and you
just see that. It's like, some guy's running out here. It's not comfortable
to run with a sign. What a crazy person. But I think
it's a really cool idea. And around our city,
there are things like the— I'm just thinking of the Eagle Monument— that people—
I really didn't know that people cared that much. Until it was gone.
Until it was gone, I was like, okay, that's like something
that for people is very important. And I think the message that you've carried,
that's pretty like a recognizable brand. In this case,
the city would just be partnering with you on some
parcels of land to put the signs in, is my understanding. Not maintaining
the signs, just put them up. And I
think we've got a lot of young kids that I think that message really resonates.
Thank you. And there's other things you would have to consider, right? Where we put
them. Someone might like to get out and take a picture, right? So don't put
them in precarious places. And just, we'd have to be really strategic
about how we do that. Make sure it's safe, make sure it's clearly visible.
But then again, like you said, let's not put them everywhere.
Let's put 'em in key places that would make a big impact.
And yeah, thank you for that.
So I'm meeting with Cedar Fort later this week to discuss
like a race within the valley here. Cedar Fort
has some need to raise funds for their fire department.
We have some need to raise funds for our volunteer police.
But I was thinking it may be interesting to add an element of this,
of what you have, into that. But I may coordinate with
you offline about that. Very cool. Yeah, I've wanted to do a race. I actually
looked into it a couple years back. Somebody I'm very busy. I don't
make money doing this, right? So I don't want to, but somebody went to organize
a race for me and then they kind of— something happened and they backed out,
so I wasn't able to do it. I think we could put together something that
would be pretty powerful in the, in the valley here. So I'll be in touch
with you on that. Very cool. I'd love that. Thank you. So,
Mayor, if I can just— maybe I can wrap it up. What I'm hearing is
support from the council to move forward
in trying to become Believer City. and maybe working out the details of what that
means as we go forward. Is that a fair assessment?
Yes. Melissa? Yes. Okay. All right. That's exactly what I was wondering
is what do we want to do from here? Is there more discussion or can
we sign up and then work out sign locations? So I think the direction
is to have staff, whoever that is, to go ahead and log on and become
a Believer City. And then as needs come in,
is there any action item required on that? Marcus, are we
okay just to— We can put it on the legislative priority
list. Be generous. You know, I mean, I think if,
uh, the mayor feels comfortable moving forward,
given the, the discussion went, then I think you have the authority to move
forward. I don't think there needs to be a vote on it and be that
formal about it. If that's— yeah, that's why I was making sure. So if that's
the general consensus, I think we'll have Uh, Ben, direct somebody
to look into this. And then as the sign locations, things like that become
needs, we'll have to approve those as they come in, each, each one other,
and just sign it up for now. Mayor, I also think it would be useful
if we were to do like a resolution or a proclamation
at some point down the road. It doesn't have to be tied to signing up,
but kind of declaring that we are a Believer City, I think,
is that way all of the council can vote on that too.
Yeah, I think that would be fun. I was actually thinking earlier today about reading,
you know, like we've done before, today's whatever day,
you know, that today we're recognizing El Monte as a believer
city. So I think that's something we can do in the near future as we,
as we progress. So that works. Thank you
very much. Awesome. Looks like we'll be signing up. Thank you so much.
Thanks for your time. Thanks, Ben. Okay, we're gonna go back to item 1A,
a discussion about tax increment financing and bonding options. And we have with us—
do you want to lead into that? Or I think we can turn it right
over to Laura Lewis, our bond counsel, and she can help us
understand the needs of our bonding.
Thank you for allowing me just a few minutes when I arrived. I appreciate that.
I am Laura Lewis, your municipal advisor with LRB
Public Finance Advisors. Randy Larson with Gilmore
Bell is bond counsel, and they would be preparing all the legal documents
And since we're going to discuss different options of how you might want to secure
the financing, I've asked him to be here if you have any
questions in that regard. Because of our timing, we may
have to move sort of with like a, you know, dual-pronged approach.
So I'm going to hand out— did this— I don't know if I sent this
in time for it to get up on the screen, so I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Did everybody get one? I've got more. I won't be able to sell them afterwards,
so.
All right. Well, we're here to talk about the financing for
a project that's needed in conjunction with a development
within the RDA area. The funds will be used to accelerate
offsite infrastructure improvements of Old Airport Road
and Lake Mountain Corridor, which, you know, if it
weren't for this, they would get built to like the minimum, if you will.
And someone else in the room that's an engineer or whatever
could give you more detail. But otherwise, they would be built to a more minimum
standard. With this financing, they'll be able to build, uh, you know,
the full width, put in turn lanes, and all of those things,
which will be, um, very beneficial for the city.
The, uh, terms of the development agreement with the developer
within the CRA haven't changed. We're not here to discuss any of that. The arrangement's
still the same. The participation will be for the city as well as
the county— different, um, percentages of participation—
but the city and county will each participate by allowing the,
um, a portion of the sales tax generated just off this new development
to support the, the cash flows for the bonds.
Same duration, so everything there that you've talked about before, um,
remains the same. The general finance
plan— so I, um, you know, remind all of my clients
frequently that what we, um, you know, what you identify as the
cash source to repay the debt doesn't necessarily necessarily have to be
what you use as security. They can be one and the same,
probably, well, I'm going to say 80% of the time they are, maybe only 70%,
but sometimes we pledge a certain thing.
So an example might be in Ogden. So if they did a
parking structure, but at the time they weren't collecting parking
revenues, so we pledged the asset as opposed to the
revenue stream. So it doesn't always have to be, you know, what you're actually
financing. So the finance plan here is there's an independent
third-party entity by the name of EPS Denver that is conducting
a study relative to the sales taxes that will be generated
off of— they project will be generated
off of just this project area. And they
have national databases for how much a, you know, fill in the blank, a home
improvement store or grocery store or super mega Walmart
or whatever might produce. That's a lot of money. And they are pulling
that together along with data that they are able to get
locally. Utah law prescribes
that that data be maintained under very strict ways
that it can be delivered to them, that they can use it in studies.
But they are trying to dial down so that you and the bondholders have
a very good idea of what those revenues are likely to be.
We anticipate a delivery of like the numbers
related to that by the end of this month, so in a little over a
week, and the full written report by the middle of
June. The timing is such so that they would
like to get under construction by the end of July, like shovels
in the ground. And so we've got a little bit of a mismatch in terms
of like waiting for all of that final data before you
decide how you'd like to um, finance it. And so we're here
tonight to discuss it so you can sort of see the, you know, the pros
and cons of different options. Um, I did see, uh,
an email that, uh, your city manager sent to you, and I wanted to hire
him because he did a— Well,
that's good for you. Good for you.
He did a flawless job of giving you, uh, information in advance,
so it will allow me to go through this a little bit faster.
So the debt will be structured based on what we see those projected revenues to
be. Our goal will be to structure the debt. If we think the projected revenues
are here, we'll put the debt right in, we'll try to tuck it right in
so that the finance plan will be for those revenues to repay the debt.
So again, with the finance plan, the finance, we know what the revenue is going
to be. Now we have to discuss how you want to backstop it, if you
want to backstop it, to further securitize that loan.
So option 1 will be just to pledge the sales tax
tax increment that is coming off of that project area.
And as Ben described in his information to you,
should we get those, you know, that data back and we go, oh, well,
it looks like for every dollar we have in debt, we have $1.01
in likely revenue, that might be a very difficult bond
to sell, right? These are projections. They are trying to be conservative. We have
been conservative. So Ideally,
in order to sell it as a tax increment bond only,
that's the only thing that we're pledging, then I would like to have
1.5 times coverage. So for every $1.50 you
get in TIF revenue, we would structure it so that your debt
payment would only be $1. Therefore, if there's
a bad disease, we're spreading,
people don't shop as much for a while or whatever, you've got some headroom.
Thank you. Under your development agreement,
you would still capture all of that revenue and
you would seek to set it aside to use it as soon as you
could, depending upon the bond structure, to call the bonds. So it wouldn't
be lost. It just gives some headroom and comfort to, you know,
the bondholders about that revenue stream. Because of that,
you know, as we go through these 3 options, think about if I were buying
that bond, right? If you're the bond purchaser, that's going to
be your highest-risk bond. What do they want for risk?
Brett knows. They want a higher return, right?
So that's the highest-risk bond. You know, we'll structure it so that
it's likely to be very successful, but there's nothing
else behind it. Sales taxes don't come off of that specific project.
Oh dear, right? We're in trouble, right? So that's going to carry
a higher interest rate. I've got a summary table with data on on
their About the Rates here in a little bit. That transaction
also, because of its— it won't carry a rating,
there's a likelihood that we may want to do that as a direct
purchase as opposed to a public offering. There's both good
and bad with the direct purchase. I just mention it because it's different and the
numbers on here may show a little bit different. That's option 1.
Option 2 is the same Tax
increment pledge. So again, we're still planning on using those revenues,
but instead of just leaving it, you know, alone, the city
can choose to backstop it with your moral obligation.
What that means is the city would adopt a resolution that
says if there are insufficient revenues to make that debt payment,
then we would consider— it does not obligate you— we would consider
making up the differential.
The obligation would require you to put that
shortfall amount into your budget so that you have to actively take
it out, but it doesn't force you to make the payment.
It just is a show of good faith that, you know, they're not just going
to, oh yeah, we said that, but, you know, no one is ever going to
get it on the budget, right? It's a show of good faith that you would
put it in the budget. You could again, very easily and actively take it
out. You're not obligated to do it under that option.
The city's credit is high enough that the bond market would view that very strongly
because they're gonna say, eh, they're not gonna wanna stiff
us on this deal, right? So it's going to sell well, but again,
know that you're not obligated. The third
option is sort of the full punch.
Again, we pledge the tax increment from that project area,
but instead of just having the moral obligation, the city can
choose to make a binding
commitment and pledge citywide sales tax
to repay that obligation from that small portion
if it doesn't generate enough to pay the debt service. I would
advise that if you do that, that we do that pledge on a subordinate basis,
Meaning that your other sales tax bondholders would get paid
first, and any other bonds that you put on parity
with that would get paid first. And from the
remaining sales tax revenue, you would pay any
shortfall from that other from the from the subset
area of this development. So with
that, then quantitatively on page the bottom of page. 3.
You can see the options laid out with what the construction fund—
I mean, construction funds are the same across the board, that $8 million I mentioned.
In some of the structures, in the TIF-only structure
and the moral obligation structure,
there's still enough of a risk that we would want to— for the
bondholders so they will buy the bonds, we would want to fund a debt service
reserve fund from the bond proceeds. So the The city doesn't have to come up
with the money. It comes out of the bond. It gets released to make the
last payment. But it's a cushion there. If it's TIF only,
again, if you're a bondholder, got your bondholder hat on, if it's
TIF only and the development's
slow or whatever happens that means that there's a little bit
of a shortfall, that gives them a cushion to draw on that reserve.
Right? If the city— so you go to option 3. If the
city chooses to backstop it with a subordinate Sales tax pledge,
we don't need to fund that reserve because your you know current
sales tax bond rating I think is a double A minus,
and it's viewed as a very strong credit. You have gobs
of sales tax revenue, so they wouldn't be worried about getting paid. So we wouldn't
have to fund that reserve fund. The cost of issuance are going
to be a little bit higher with a non-rated bond because we have to you
know pay the underwriter more to. sell, you know, that security,
or if we do a direct purchase, we may— there may
be a purchaser fee they have to pay to review the credit. So you
can see the difference in the par amount of the bonds. It goes down with
the, you know, bettering of the credit, so to speak, for those reasons.
The amortization is the same straight across. I anticipate
the rating to be non-rated on option 1, middle of the road on
option A+ to AA- with a subordinate sales
tax pledge. I think it will be
a little bit less than your current regular sales tax bonds
because these are subordinate to that. You see the difference in interest rates
as a TIF pledge only about— I'm guessing in today's market would
be about at a 6.20. On the other option,
the bookends, so to speak, I think we could get a subordinate
sales sales tax done at about a 4.12% over that 15 years.
You see the differentials in average annual payment. On the high end, it's $930,000
a year. On the lower end with the sales tax backstop, it's $732,000.
Then you can just see the difference in that amount paid over time.
One way I at least want you to think about this is if
the city is willing, again, they are all great options.
we'll be able to get the bonds done. But if you are willing to
either give us a moral obligation or a subordinate
sales tax backstop, that means that the— because again, what are we going to use
to repay this no matter what? The TIF off the project area, right?
Well, if the interest rate is lower, there's a higher likelihood that's going
to cover the debt. There's a higher likelihood we'll be able to pay it off
sooner. So there are advantages to doing it that way. But I
know the one probably big concern or question. Drum roll
to the next page. Top of page 4 is what will that
impact be if we go ahead and make that pledge?
And I should have had to make it a different color. My old eyes have
a hard time seeing it, but I'll point it out for you and get out
your magnifying glass. If you do choose
to support the transaction with a subordinate
sales tax pledge, What could we— we've
got other projects we need to do, Laura, and you want to be able to
finance them with, you know, possibly with sales tax backing depending upon what
they are. So the graph at the top of page 4,
that top blue line is what your current sales tax
revenues are. It's $12 million and change. Maybe it's all $13 million.
Now the anticipated for 2026 is in the
$13 million range. So that's your sales tax. Again, you can
see we're holding it flat. That's not true. A quiz, has your sales
tax been flat? Nope. Nope.
Shoo, it goes up because you've got a lot of growth,
you've got a lot of new commercial coming into town. So again, this is a
very conservative look at that. If your sales tax
revenue remained constant at the $13 million and
change, that little blue, the little blue bar at the
top of this is would be the 2026 subordinate
pledge. So you can see, yes, it takes up some of that headroom, but not
a lot. The green bar is— oh,
the orange bar is your current sales tax outstanding
bonds. The green bars are what the hypothetical
debt is. What is your bandwidth? If you were gonna go to the max,
we're gonna borrow up to that 2 times coverage and
build to your little heart's content, and you could bond for about
$82 million. Okay. today with no sales
tax revenue increase, right, which you're likely to have?
$82 million. $82 million. I'm not advocating you spend it all,
but you have a lot of capacity is
the point here. So that if you agree or decide
to do the backstop, you're not, you know,
losing anything, because I don't think you're planning on bonding for $82 million.
If so, Randy and I will be like, woo-hoo. So with
that, your— the other thing
is, will this have any impact on the sewer bonds that you need to
issue because of, you know, the expansion that's needed at your treatment plant?
And the answer to that is no. There will be no impact because those bonds—
again, we've talked about what secures each bond, right? What secures those bonds
are water, sewer, and storm sewer revenues after you pay operations and maintenance.
Yes. So do the bondholders care, the rating agencies care about
the general health of the city? Yes. Will this have any direct impact
on those bonds? No, not at all.
Let's see, last but not least, I've got some stuff on the
current market conditions. I was telling Evan I could just put a tornado
there because that's what it feels like, right?
Every day is a new whatever. Municipal bond rates in
the last week have followed the increase in Treasury yields,
not, you know, basis point by basis point, but they
have gone up. Treasury rates have actually gone up more. It's making
long-end municipal bonds harder to sell because there's a bigger divergence
between those two on the long end. If any of you
listen to the news, you probably know what's driving market conditions largely right now.
I mean, there's always, you know, economic data coming out,
but, you know, the concern— excuse
me— over, you know, the oil not flowing freely through the Strait
of Hormuz and what's that going to do to the world economy.
Yeah, EIA petroleum— you have had to save me with water
before. Thank you. The petroleum status report
is due tomorrow. FOMC minutes are going to be released tomorrow. So depending upon
that petroleum report, it might not be a great market in the— great day in
the market. You know, we watch jobless claims, et cetera.
You can see the historical bond indices.
We're at not the peak, you know,
since 2016 on the municipal side,
but we're on the higher end. If we were to take this graph and look
like back since the dawn of time, because I'm really old,
I remember when interest rates I was in the mortgage industry in the
early '80s. Well, they were like 18% mortgages, if you can imagine. So if
we looked at this over a longer period of time, this is close-ish to
average. It's a little bit above average. So it's not a bad
time to issue bonds. It's never wise to play the market,
particularly in a volatile market, because heaven only knows what tomorrow's going
to bring. On the last page, we've got what
the AAA municipal market data— so this is a tax-exempt
historical historical look at a tax-exempt benchmark.
And with that, I'm going to turn a little bit of time
over to Randy to talk to you about the— under the 3 options, what legal
documents you would have to adopt as an RDA
and as a city council. If you could take a minute to
do that. Okay with that? Mayor, can I ask some questions,
or do we want to wait? I think this might
be relevant, so I wasn't sure if you were ready for questions. Yeah, I thought
I'd let him talk and then he or I will answer your questions. So let's
have Randy talk and then we'll go to questions.
You bet. I'll be, I'll be quick like the lawyer at the end of a
commercial. Okay, the, uh, the city will need to
adopt a resolution for either the moral obligation pledge
or the sales tax subordinate pledge. For the TIF bonds,
that will be the CRA. So of course the city council is the governing body,
but that will be the one that takes action to issue the bonds.
Um, for all 3 of those, they, uh,
there is a notice and a 30-day contest period
that follows, um, the, uh, the date of
adoption, how quickly we can get it into the newspaper. Mm-hmm. But there is not
a public hearing for any of the 3 proposals that Laura has discussed,
uh, required in that, in in that process,
okay? Trying to think if there's anything else
that would— well, parallel would be the project area
for the CRA, and I don't know exactly where we're at with that, but we
could run parallel to create the project area
to allow for the sales tax increment to be collected, and we
could run that parallel with the bonds, but that would be a parallel legal process
to the bonding process. Okay. Sound good?
That was quick for an attorney. Just wait
till I send you my documents. He'll make up for it, trust me. Oh yeah.
I'll be just recusing myself from the vote,
but just from an education— I don't— I'm not giving any
investment advice to the council. So I just want to be clear on that.
But I— Laura, thank you for your presentation. That was really succinct and
super helpful. The one question I had was going back to, to the
debt capacity. You mentioned the $82 million.
If, if we were to take out debt, let's say for a city hall or
something not commercially related, yes, is that
something we need to factor into this $82 million number, or could
Would that be outside as like a general obligation? Is this just looking at commercial
tax? This is just looking at sales tax, yes. So if
you were to finance a city hall, a rec center, parks, fire station, all of
those kind of vertical projects,
all of those could be done with a GO vote, could be done
with sales tax as the security. Or it can be
done with the actual physical facility as a security as well.
Now, in order of interest rate,
again, I started with the lowest interest rate is going to be GO bond.
Second will be the sales tax, and those are probably 10
or 15 basis points from each other, so not even a whole quarter percent,
but there will be some difference. And then probably add a quarter percent
or 25 basis points to that if you did it as a building authority.
Building authority is how we secure if
we pledge the real property as the asset. So I'd want to like know,
I mean, have an idea. Nobody knows the future, right? But I'd want to know
like, okay, is the plan to finance a city hall and
then a rec center? If we had some idea of timing, right? Rec center,
the rating agencies will knock you down because they don't
view view it as essential. Now I have looked at them, you know me well
enough, I have looked at them and said citizens would rather a rec
center than a cool city hall as a general
rule. But they don't care. They view a city hall as essential. Fire station
is essential. Police station is essential. So if we were, you know,
if we wanted to say, okay, we don't want all of our sales tax capacity
used up, we want, you know, the physical facility to act
as security to one or more of these. We could do it as a building
authority, keep your sales tax capacity freed up, if you
would. And we also— this nice thing we don't do in the,
you know, personal or commercial lending
world, but local governments, we can cross-collateralize your assets.
So let's say you wanted to do a park and it's like, oh, well,
you know, bond market thinks that's nonessential. You'd still get a good rating, but you
wouldn't get as of rating if it were a city
hall. Well, we can— or a fire station. We can finance
a fire station and the park. They're cross-collateralized. You make the lease
payment on one or you make the lease payment on either of them. Similar with
city hall. So you have various options. So in a worst-case scenario,
we could max out the $82 million
for commercial-related activities and in in addition to that, do a GO
bond for a city hall or— okay. Yes. I just wanted
to be clear on that without impacting our credit rating. Yes. The second question
I had, I was just looking at, and it may just be a difference in
the credit agencies. It looks like you're using S&P. I was looking at Fitch
this morning and it had, I guess these are 15-year bonds,
but the 5-year AA I think was like at 3.7%.
We're at 4.1%. How would you compare
those? I always hedge when I'm showing numbers in the public.
So our rate could be better than what you're showing here.
Okay. To that point, I had a conversation with my colleague
that does all my quantitative analysis, and I'm like, ooh,
because he had that, the one with the sales tax backs off about a 384
or something in that neighborhood. And I'm like, ooh, Nate,
have you read the news? today, right? I mean, because it's just
a matter— I mean, if we had been marketed today, right? Yes, I think we
would be under 4. Okay. But because we're not marketing today,
I put a little bit of wiggle room in it. Again,
these aren't guaranteed rates or anything, but just again for the purpose
of, you know, not getting too dialed down and having
markets change and people go, well, you had on this piece of paper.
So I, I have been some Okay, and then maybe
just 2 more quick questions. We have the ability to prepay.
Is there a limited amount of time that we could pay? It depends
on the structure. So if we did a direct purchase, the difference between direct
purchase and a public offering would be if we did a direct
purchase, we would put together a term sheet and submit
it on your behalf. It would state right at the top that we are acting
as your municipal advisor, and purchasers would know that.
We would submit it to purchasers, I think most of which,
maybe one, that we have a list of probably 12 or
so that we're sending those out to. I think all but one
of them would be a bank, bank that you'd be familiar with their name.
If that direct purchaser were to buy the bonds, we don't
need an underwriter. We don't need an offering document. We still need a
plethora of legal documents, but we don't need an offering document.
Typically, with direct purchase,
they will— some of the purchasers will view it as having an edge
if they allow the bonds to be callable at any time.
So it's one of the things that in addition to rate, they'll say, okay,
we'll give you rate X and we'll allow it to be callable at
any time. Another entity may say, we'll give you rate, you know,
X minus, but we won't allow it to be
callable. So it's one of the things, if we do a direct purchase, we get
all the stuff back. We, you know, put together a nifty little spreadsheet
so that you can see all the, you know, options, if you will, and we
work with the city, your finance director and city manager, to choose what's going to
be best for you. In that instance, I think
it would be highly likely that they would be callable Maybe not any time,
but I bet we could at least get down to a 5-year call, maybe a
1-year call without a penalty.
If we do a public offering,
the standard currently is to have 10-year par bonds,
so we wouldn't be able to prepay them until year 10. For a decade.
We can— we've been able to negotiate with— when bonds are being structured
with 5% coupons, we can usually get away with a 9-year par call.
If you said, I want to have them callable sooner, well,
every year I come down, that's going to drive your interest rate up. That changes
in the market, and typically, it doesn't
get very cost-effective to get too demanding beyond like a 7-year.
You really start to lose the edge you might
think you are going to get by having that bond callable, because you're paying more
in yield for it. Okay. Thank you. Can I ask one
clarifying question, Mayor? Laura, how is MET calculated?
Is it part of the sales tax revenue calculation, or is it
a separate consideration? Can you see the deer
in the headlights? Clearly it's separate.
Okay, and that's what I thought. I just wanted to make sure that I was
thinking correctly, that it is separate, because that's also another revenue stream.
That could be pledged towards something, perhaps if the city decides to
go in a different direction. Oh, municipal energy tax. Hello.
I just— I didn't— I was— as you could see,
I was like, MET. I was thinking tax terms.
Municipal energy tax. Yes, you can. You can also pledge
that. We can pledge that in conjunction with or
separate too. So let's say you just use, you know, the sales tax
here. Then you could pledge your municipal energy tax
to a park to support a park bond. So it was a good question.
I'm sorry I wasn't up to speed on my acronyms. So the municipal energy tax
is calculated into this— into the graphs that you provided?
It is not included. That is correct. Thank you.
Laura. Yes. You're going to throw another acronym at me? No, I hate them.
You'll never hear me say an acronym. And I should have known that one.
I'll say it. My question's actually, what happens to the bond
should the state take over the road maintenance? They designated it as
a state road. Do we continue to pay on the bond till the end of
the bond? Yes, unless you can negotiate something with the state to pay you.
I mean, never say never. I would ask,
certainly, but my guess is that they would likely say, oh, we're taking the
maintenance. Too bad, you paid for it. But never say never.
If there aren't any other questions, I, I think— are we looking for specifically
which of the 3 options we're comfortable with? That, that would be preferable
because it allows us to— allows us— it allows him to
write up the various documents. Yep, Mr. Larson will need to prepare the
documents, and there are 3 different sets. If it's depending upon which option,
it's best to have some consensus. I'll speak first, Mayor,
if you'll let me. I think we should do the one where we, we We
guarantee the security. I mean, we get a lower interest rate. I also am uncomfortable
with setting aside $900,000 or $800,000 that sits in that
revenue fund that sits on the front end. It reduces
the amount of money that we can put to work,
and that money becomes worth less and less as we have to sit on that
for 15 years. So I just— The third option makes
the most sense to me. It's certainly the the safest for the bondholders
and probably the riskiest for the city.
Sorry, but I also think that we get the best bang for our buck.
Are you stating option 3 just for clarity? Okay.
I'm in the same boat. I think that that puts us in the strongest
position to be able to do all the things that we know we're gonna have
to tackle in the next couple of years. And it makes
sense to go for the lowest interest rate possible. So I'm in
agreeing with Councilmember Wright. And I kind of heard whispers
on this side that everybody says Option 3. So for sake of time, I think,
uh, it looks like Option 3 is,
is our preference. So is there any other needs
on this specific item that you guys need, or— Nope. Thank you for your time.
Appreciate it. Thank you. Thank you both.
All right, moving right along. We will move to discussion item
1C. This is about recreation events sponsorship and advertising.
This, I know Steve Mumford has a little bit and also our Community Services Board
Chair Jesse Southworth, and Melissa also wanted to
lead in with a little bit. You're welcome to plug in for the presentation.
While she's walking up here, I just wanted to let the rest of council know
that I, first, I love being a liaison to this board. But second,
Jesse and I had a really great opportunity to meet with Jason Hall and Mayor
and just talk about the state of soccer and where we're headed and some of
those things. And as a part of that conversation,
making sure that we're competitive in what we offer
our kids that sign up was a big part
of the discussion. And as we got into that, we started talking about ways
to pay for that and it naturally led to a conversation about
sponsorships for soccer and just rec things.
And I felt more comfortable bringing it back to the body so
that everyone would have a chance to weigh in on it. And that's kind of
where we are today. So— And then, Viss, before you get started,
Steve, did you have anything that you wanted to lead in with? Just to note
that Jason Hall and Dawn Hancock are here to answer questions.
I know Jessie's going to— she's taking taken this on and is going to present
and answer your questions and represent our board as
well. But she'll talk about sports and
events a little bit as well. So as you're thinking of sponsorships,
we're thinking of the whole gamut. So yep,
turn it over to Jessie. Thank you,
one second, sorry. It's real
weird.
Okay, I don't know why.
All right, good afternoon, Mayor and Council. Um, so the
Community Services Board would like to explore sponsorship
opportunities for recreation programs and community events.
Uh, right now the city does not accept any sponsorships for
recreation programs, but I know they've been used in the past for events,
but nothing formal has ever been, uh,
created or followed. Um, and I think that's just a missed opportunity,
so I wanted to take this on. Um,
today I'm not asking for any, like, official final approval
of a sponsorship program. We just simply are looking for direction on whether
or not the board should move forward with discussing and developing a formal sponsorship
policy framework. If there is support, we would work
through the details and bring a recommendation back to the council for review.
I think why this is worth doing, sponsorships create
a win-win-win situation without burdening families with higher fees or
putting everything on taxpayers. Sponsorships would directly improve
resident residents' experiences. They allow for lower costs to
participate, better equipment and facilities, access to scholarships
for those who need them, and overall higher quality programs.
Local businesses want to support their community, and sponsorships give them
an organized, meaningful channel to do that while building goodwill.
And sponsorships would help stretch the city's budget further
and reduce the burden of municipal funding.
As you can see here, many of our neighboring cities
already have sponsorship programs in place. They range anywhere
from— most of them are around $300 to around
$25,000. And that shows to me 2 things.
First, there's a lot of flexibility in how a program can be structured. And second,
there's real potential to improve the recreation program services and events provided
for our residents. This is a closer
look at what Saratoga Springs offers for their recreation sponsorships,
and it would be a fairly simple plan
for us to recreate. Each tier provides additional benefits,
giving businesses more visibility and value at higher sponsorship levels.
My personal belief is that we should start with the jersey
logo sponsorships. They're simple, clear, and would require
minimal effort to implement. These images show
what leagues in our area are already doing, including the Eagle Mountain Youth
Soccer, which is who we partnered with, one of the club teams,
Liverpool, and even you've got Real Salt Lake there. The approach
would help offset costs, allow us to provide higher quality
materials, and improve the overall experience for our recreation participants.
For event sponsorships, I pulled Lehigh as an example.
This model provides an organized path with clear expectations for both the
city and potential sponsors. We could do something similar or start
even with a simpler version.
And then the final question is,
are you comfortable with the board continuing to explore the overall concept
of the sponsorships? And more importantly, are there any concerns,
limits, or red lines you would— we should be aware of before we go further?
I'll add too really quick that we had the opportunity to meet with
Jason. We haven't sat down with Dawn yet to find out what her desire and
needs are, but that would be a part of the Community Services Board's process
before they did anything to really get feedback
from events. I personally
think this is a great way to lift some cost from the parents.
That's the direction that we're going. Um, it also gives
an opportunity for businesses to market throughout
the community and contribute to the community maybe in other ways that they
can't. So I, I am fine with it.
The one thing that I'm just kind of thinking through what,
what kind of events would we have sponsored. I, I, I think in
some events it might be okay, in other events— and maybe Don could guide us
on where we could do support as a city— but we also want to be
careful to not, I guess, playing favorites. If you go up to
Idaho Falls for the 4th of July, it's a Melaleuca fireworks
show even though it's Idaho Falls. Right. So we just need to be careful to
make sure that we're retaining the events that we want to support and farming
out events that maybe we're okay with third parties paying
for. But I love the idea of jerseys for sure.
The thought that just kind of came to my mind along those lines is if
you have a sponsorship partner that suddenly
is somebody we don't want to be a partner with because something happens, we need
to have the capability of being able to absorb whatever that sponsorship
So to his point about a fireworks show, let's say that our sponsor, whoever that
might be, suddenly has done something in the media, everybody hates them. Right.
We need to be able to have the capability of being able to pull out
of something like that. Second thing, love the idea with
the jerseys. I think that's smart. I'd say let's go even further
and, and go after the field markers, all of that kind
of things, things that There's a cost associated with that we could do better with
and have better ways of marking things. I think those are great
things. I do think there's a maybe an argument to be made as separating them
so that there are sponsorships for recreation and sponsorships for events,
and depending on the event, I mean, obviously with like some
of our big events, maybe we want to structure that differently, right?
To be able to. get a sponsorship goal that we need to
get to, to be able to fund this as part of our,
you know, getting t-shirts or something like that for all of our volunteers or whatever.
I think if you keep it separate, maybe it's a little easier to manage what
the sponsorship looks like. Last question, who's responsible for seeking the sponsorships
every year? The Community Services Board. So you
guys will be making telephone calls to businesses?
Yes. That's, that's the question. Or, I mean,
unless there's a better solution, but as of now, I think— I think that's
got to be part of what we make the decision on, that there's a plan
in place that we put in place. Because if you're not on the Community Services
Board in 4 years, does the next person behind you have the same passion to
chase after that? And then do we lose kind of that benefit? So I think
whatever we do, it needs to have the ability to ex— I will say
this, They get hit by a bus. If you get hit by a bus tomorrow,
does the next person have those things in place? Well, I do it for me
all the time too, because like if I'm the person with the passion and nobody
else has it, does it move on past me?
And I think if we're going to have success with it, it needs to be
built in where it doesn't require you to be successful.
Okay. I totally support this. I think it's awesome. And this is the creativity and
energy that I was hoping that this board would provide. And it's amazing to feel
that already with the board as new as it is. I think it's awesome.
Kudos to what you're doing, and, uh, thank you. Uh, local first,
I think, yes. Uh,
I would say if there's a tie in terms of like 2 businesses vying for
one spot, then it would go to the local business. Right. Okay. I think that's
where I would go with that. But I think regional sponsors, certainly whoever's willing to
help out here, I'm totally good with. So Yeah, thank you.
Develop the policy, Jesse, with your board. I, I love the idea. I like the
creativity. You guys figure it out and come tell us how it's going to function.
Okay. We've talked about this a little bit
already, but, um, one of the other things that came up in our discussions was
making sure that we're not putting ourselves in a position that
we're competing with already local nonprofits that are trying to do
good in the community. And I think that you have Some cool ideas to address
that. So I'm excited to see what you guys come up with. Thank you.
Thank you.
You look like you had a second idea. All right,
I think that gives us pretty good direction to work on and
go ahead and start with the policy and come back. Okay, thank you. Thanks.
All right. Good work. We'll move back.
Yeah, thank you. Everybody said good work with no mic on.
Uh, 1D discussion for Corrigan Farms rezones. Senior Planner
David Stroud.
All right,
Mayor and Council, again, this is a discussion item tonight for
the Corrigan Farms. I'll show you the general
location aerial here. As you can see, we're near QTS,
we're near Meta. In fact, the yellow line
is the boundary between the city and the county. In fact,
the property that is there in the red obviously is a corrugated.
That's actually the staging site right now for the contractor trailers and whatnot
for QTS. But the applicant had approached the city and
requested initially the industrial zone. One of the comments we had
from staff was RTI is probably would
be a better zone there. And so looking at the zoning map,
you can see The property with the
red square. The property is currently surrounded
on 3 sides by the RTI zone. And then of course the county
to the west. So that was our recommendation
that the RTI zone would probably be the best option if you're going to rezone
due to the nature that RTI currently surrounds the property on 3 sides.
And so we present that tonight as a discussion item for
you. 100%, yes.
Yeah, I'm— RTI is what it
ought to be. I think that's the whole purpose of this. So yeah, I'm assuming
you're going to bring this back in a formal rezone then? Excuse me? You'll be
bringing this back in a formal rezone? Yeah, yeah, I would come back. Yeah,
we're just discussing. I get your, your feedback. If something
you think is more appropriate there, great, let's discuss. But, uh, no, I think this
is always been the intent of this area. The RTI fits the narrative of
what we're trying to do in that area, leaving the underlying zone there.
So I think the rest of it's all agricultural and RTI. So,
and if it's any consolation, I'm sure the county zoning— Brandon
may be able to speak— it's probably RA-5 out there as well, which is similar
to our ag zone as it is. So,
okay. The only question I had was,
why was it not rezoned with with the RTI initially?
I, I— the applicant can speak to, I believe, looking at the county records.
I think Corrigan, at least the name Corrigan, it could be the same group,
but, but that name is fairly new to that parcel, so it could be newer
owners. Because this time, previous owners may have been— I don't
think it was QTS's property. I think it's being sold to them. That's my understanding.
Yeah. Okay. Maybe the previous owners didn't— Yeah. Hey, we don't,
we don't want to do that. Who knows?
Okay, thank you. It sounds like bring
it back. And then if I know you've got the next one, Deer Run
concept plans. So unless you had more to add, let's move right on to Deer
Run. Okay, Deer Run is a request from Ivory Homes.
The property— here's the aerial. You can see it's on the north side
of SR 73 and the newly extended
portion of Airport Road. The property you see there in blue,
zoning of the property is foothill residential, and the applicant has drawn
up a concept plan based on that foothill residential.
Zooming in a little bit, you can see there is an important aspect
to this property, and that's the deer migration corridor. Does go through the northwest corner
of that. The bump out you see there on the northeast portion
of the property as well. That is actually 2 parcels owned by the
city, and so the applicant would like to incorporate that property
as well into the project. Those those 2 parcels are
currently under the Clearview Development Agreement. The 2 biggest portions
on the Clearview Agreement are half-acre lots, and it does have equine
rights on those parcels as well.
So the potential layout that the applicant has submitted,
as you see here. We did have to massage this a bit due
to block lengths, for instance, to the adjacent Holbrook
property, which is unhighlighted on the
properties there to the west. Certainly,
I believe the applicant has been inquiring with
Holbrook on purchasing that in the future, as was related to the Planning
Commission at the previous meeting. But the applicant, bottom line,
would be a single-family development.
A couple issues for discussion would be the city
property. There is a wash that does go
through the property. Staff is of the opinion that the wash would be
best served either as open space or to the city.
The way it's drawn up right now, the property lines would go to the— the
center line of the wash would be private property.
And then of course the deer migration corridor would be another discussion
point as well. The applicant is here tonight.
The question I had is that obviously the wildlife corridor,
if that little tip or corner,
how many lots does that come back if you were to— you're
probably looking at the corridor. Yeah, to that line. What is it?
Is it lots 102, 3, 4, Yeah, 102,
maybe 103. And of course, the corner of that long
lot, 101. Obviously, whatever's done with 101,
you can't use that corner of it anyway for anything. So it probably wouldn't
affect 101 very much, if at all.
Definitely would be 102, 103, and whatever
the potential for the adjacent Holbrook property
as well. Does it cut into Lot 116, or is it just those,
those 2? I don't want to say just those 2 lots, but I would say
it probably does not affect much, if at all. And again,
you've got that long corner triangular piece which you wouldn't
be able to build or do anything with anyway, so probably wouldn't affect that one
a whole lot. Okay. If at all.
So, so what's going on with Lot 101? So Lot 101,
what, what Is going on with that? Uh,
I, I think the applicant expressed, uh,
the possible church site. Okay.
And so they would— and there would not be any access from within the development?
That would just be— the road would go along the north side
of Lot 101? Yeah, there wouldn't be any access. Certainly, as this progresses,
we would want to see— if it does become a church site, we'd want to
see at least some pedestrian access through Is
Lot 101, the size of that contributing to the overall—
like, I know you have to have a required average. Is Lot 101 sort
of pulling up that average? It's an average lot
size. I would say Brad, if you want to come
up, Brad. Brad Mackey with Ivory Homes is here.
Do you know, Brad, did that— does that factor into the
overall size of the— I believe it does, yes. Because it's
not a lot.
And the Holbrook family actually still owns that
piece and will always own that. It will be a donation
to the LDS Church from the Holbrook family.
So under our city code, if there's sort of an outlier lot,
it's actually not factored into average lot size. So that would not count
towards the average lot size, even if it remains as is. So it would still
have to comply without factoring in 101's size.
What defines an outlier? I mean, I'm paraphrasing,
but it's in the code, and I can pull it up and
quote you the verbiage if you want. But that's
the nature of it. If something is significantly larger than
all the other lots on there, then it wouldn't be counted for average lot
size purposes.
That would also apply to the parks and the other lots that
are— I don't know if they're counted there, right? But just wanted to be clear.
I know the parks were not counted as far as lots.
The park space was not counted In lots,
for sure.
Anybody else? Yeah. So I'm going to
talk to you about the roads. So what those are, the road to the north,
there's a parcel to the north that will be responsible for building part of that
when they complete theirs. I don't see half of the width of that road
being contemplated in here on the north side. We built lots
right against it. And then the road that is coming at a
northwest trajectory, it ends at the end of
your concept plan to nowhere. Then you
can show an outline of what could be possible in the future.
But in my opinion, if you're going to do that, we want to see that
connect to an actual road. What's the plan?
Is there a pointer? I can point to it with the pointer if you want.
Yeah. So this road right here that we're not showing— Yeah.
That actually goes up and over to the middle school.
That's an existing road that's being used now, even though it's not
a paved road. The property to the north is gonna be required
to build their half of it when they decide to do that. That section
is not contemplated in your half to build because you're building on
the south side of that. The same thing for here, to come to an end
here. A road that goes nowhere is no help to us.
I think— can I, can I expand on your question a little bit,
Rich? Currently, this road right here services a business, and it
actually ties on right here. So if this was to build,
there is no access right here. So I think your
question is— Well, you're actually moving the road at that point, but you're not
willing to— Because this— I understand that. I'm saying the whole
point of that is this is existing now,
we're moving it up here, but nobody's actually doing anything up here. That's not contemplated
in your plan, which it should be. And one half of the width of this
road should be your responsibility to build, and when this
other, uh, parcel is done, they will do the other half of that road.
But this road goes to nowhere. So, so let's
start with the stuff I can control, which is this road
that goes nowhere. I'm planning on picking up this parcel right here from
Steve Holbrook. It's a different family. If I
pick that up, then I will extend that up. The reason it's here is because
you have a culvert that crosses the wash right here that was installed
when we did— when we built Airport Road for you guys.
So The road would work best right here. If I can't get this
piece over here, then we will just bring the road up right in here.
That answers my question. If you don't get it— I don't love
ifs when we're saying yes to things because— Right. I want
to deal with what we have, right? So if what we have, what you're saying
is you can't get this, then this road— I think we need to show
both. There needs to be a rendering that shows, here's my if statement.
If I get this, then we're here. If we don't,
then we're committed to also going up here and connecting to that road.
The other option is we're less than 30 lots on a single access, so we
could put a, a temporary turnaround right in here.
Um, that's an— that's another option as well.
But I, I was under the impression this was concept plan,
not final or preliminary plat, so I,
I assumed we could address that down the road. As far
as this up here that you're asking about, you as the
city own this parcel and this parcel. So that would be if you
wanted to develop these 2 pieces. I was just asked to include these
on this site plan so you could see what you could do with those 2
parcels under the current ordinance. Right now, your master plan
shows this road being built and You
don't have access to those roads because it's too
close to intersections. So the only way to access your
parcels here and here is through our parcel.
So that's why those are included on this concept plan, so you could see
how those could be accessed in the future. That's true,
but then your concept plan doesn't work at all if that doesn't
happen and we don't sell this to you. It works fine because The road
is right here on your north boundary. Our boundary
where these lots are on the south side of the road. So to my point,
there's the what we have and the what we— the ifs, right? So what
we have probably needs to be this, right? And then maybe this
needs to be— if we're going to show it as a concept, if this is
sold to us, this is a possibility. If I get this, this is a
possibility. And if not, when we talk about concepts,
we're looking at Giving you instruction for you to come back and bring it as
an application. But if it's filled with too many ifs, then what are we actually
getting? Kind of, and that's kind of what I'm looking for here. If okay,
if it's an if, this is a yes, right?
This is what you're looking for right now. If you get this here,
the intent is to do this here. Right now you have this,
so there should be a road that shows that that goes all the way across.
If you buy this property from the city. Then it's going to go up
like this. You're going to get the benefit of each of these lots. That road
isn't the city's responsibility. That would be the developer's responsibility.
Those are the ifs, right? Okay.
So I would like to see a concept plan that includes the wildlife corridor.
Have you talked to the Alliance at all regarding their feelings on this?
This today coming up here was brand new to me. I— no
one's ever told me that. If you go back on your slide to that
presentation, I don't know, this leg right here has
never been shown to me, only this one right here.
And then in our— you know, I've, I've basically shown this
concept plan like 4 times to you now, I think, over the year that
we've been working on this. Um,
we agreed to put— to allow the fence along
this boundary in one of the meetings. And then if we
buy Steve Holbrook's piece, we would push that to the edge
of the wash here because I thought the whole point was
to put a fence along the north boundary to funnel everything into this wash.
So this leg right here is a whole new add-on
that I've never seen before. Because my understanding was
everything was to push with a fence across this boundary
to push it into the wash and have the deer cross right here at the
migration corridor. So I don't know where the new lake came from.
I think you'll find that the Wildlife Alliance is really,
really helpful, and they're great partners with developers.
They're not like a Sierra Club type of a group. They really want to help
you get to a yes. And, um, because we
don't currently have our biologist on staff right now, and we're working on getting a
new one, but I think they would be a useful tool
for you. And I would encourage you to connect
with them because I think they're going to help you get it to a point
where it keeps the special about Eagle Mountain
and we can move forward with it. Okay, Brad, I'm gonna, I'm gonna say
this. I think this is important for you to hear. Hear and to understand.
That's not a new leg. It's been there for a long time. I think
it's unfortunate that we probably didn't communicate very
clearly to you as you've been having those conversations
internally, or even with council, that that is
part of the wildlife corridor that we really want to try to preserve.
And I do think it's that part of the reason for that is we've been
missing our friend Todd Black. I mean, had he been Right. And working on
staff, you would have been aware of this a long, long time ago. Well,
that's, that's who I met with. Yeah. That talked
about the fencing plan. Yeah. And I mean, it also, at least
for me, and I just want to make this point with my fellow council members,
I've been trying to make this point for a while. I think it's one of
the reasons why we need someone that is qualified and focused
on these types of planning issues that we're dealing with, in particular with the Wildlife
corridor on staff. I'm going
to just leave that there. They'll know what I'm talking about with regard to that.
So, and then I likewise agree with the with the
staff's recommendation about the wash being under city control, and I'd be I'd be curious
to hear the council's thoughts on on that aspect of the
the city owning maintaining control of the wash that's going through there instead
of it being private ownership. Or do you have, do you have a strong feeling
on that?
I have ambiguous feelings. I own part of the wash that runs through my yard,
right? Um, so I do have ambiguous feelings,
and, and I've watched what some of my neighbors have done that
I wish they hadn't done, if I'm being completely frank.
Um, I think there's, I think there's At least there's some wisdom in the city
owning it and being able to monitor and control and take care of it
and have consistency in the way that it's treated. I think that
there's some wisdom in that, but I also understand from a development side that
what you're doing is you're taking acreage out of their lots, and that's difficult
for me to find a place where I feel comfortable
in requiring that. Thank you. Well, and here's my response to that, because I think
when we are encountering circumstances like this where there's a wildlife corridor,
where there's a wash, we need to be
a little bit more flexible perhaps on some density that,
okay, they're going to lose some lots from the wildlife corridor. I don't
think that's necessarily appropriate for us to just have
them lose that. And so You know, somehow, and I don't know how,
you know, an engineer would have to look at that and say, okay, well,
we're gonna lose some lots here. Maybe we can incorporate them
somewhere else within that development. I mean, that's— I don't wanna
see any developer or landowner lose money because there's
a wildlife corridor going through there. I don't think that's appropriate to ask. So that's
something where I would be flexible in working with the developer in that
regard. Thank you. And maybe on the wash, maybe just
if there's a trail through there. I don't know. I mean, I don't know.
I guess that's something we're still up in the air about what we want to
do. Well, I'll just— I think there's room, Brad, to have
a conversation that addresses all of these
things kind of in concert as
an overall 30,000-foot view. I mean, we have the wash to deal with.
We have city-owned property to deal with from my perspective.
We have the roads, the road connectivity, and, and the wildlife corridor.
I just think there's— I think there's a lot more discussion that probably needs
to happen before I'm going to feel comfortable saying this is a great concept plan,
let's move forward with it. I think it's a good start.
It's helped us identify some of the issues that perhaps we're going to have,
and I think it, it is going to necessitate some broader conversations,
more in-depth conversations with you and with your, your team.
And, and does that happen here or with
staff, or where, where would you like that to happen? My suggestion would be to
bring 2 council members in at a time and just rotate through them. I don't—
I mean, I don't know. I don't know how anybody else feels about that.
I'd be happy to participate in that. I think every council member here would.
And maybe we can find a consensus and a way to kind of deal with
those things, because there are a lot of issues with this, but I think it's
a really neat piece of property that if it's
done right and if we're working together and we're not putting up—
we're not putting up walls, but we're taking those down and we're trying to
figure it out together— I think that it can really be an asset to
this part of the city and to you as a development company.
I agree, and we're glad to work with you.
Yeah, I'd be happy to to visit as well. And I tend to agree with
Councilmember Whiting on if you lose a couple lots,
102, 103, being flexible, maybe adding in a couple
smaller lots within the neighborhood somewhere else to, to pick that back
up. And if we just took the square footage out of the wash and said
there's this much square footage lost, we can— yeah,
yeah, yeah. I like horse trading. Good.
Yeah. Yeah, it's all good. I would just add this,
and, and I don't have much of a say, but I do have an opinion.
And I know this got rezoned to where it was because of
the, uh, some urgency for
this road. To my knowledge, this is not zoned currently, correct?
Correct. And just as a caution to the council,
I know Craig immediately mentions a trade for some density.
This is in the ACUB area, which has has some buffering, uh,
requirements, which they don't want housing at all. I personally, when this
was rezoned, was the only no vote. Uh, I didn't think it should be housing
at all. This, uh, has no entitlement. It's shown here with
some pretty high density already. With that said,
at a minimum, I, I advocated my guts out to
get that at 1 acre plus, even 2.5 acres.
So when you say density, that might be 1 acre as opposed
to 2.5, as opposed to not housing at all.
So, so even if that was there, I would just say remember there's
no entitlements on that. Can I revise my, my request? I think you should meet
with 2 council members and the mayor. Let me say it that way. And I
may or may not be in that room, and at the end of the day
I don't have a vote. But you, Rich, did you want
to— And you all know that I have a lot more tied up
in the area. Sure. So I think as we
move forward— Horse trading, right? Uh,
well, no, no, no, I, I don't want to horse trade on that. I just
want to say as we move forward, we probably
need to plan the whole area and, and not—
I mean, this one piece, we know what it's zoned, and I
need to move forward on it. But we also have
a whole lot more than just this that has bigger implications
on what we're doing in the city. So really, we need to bring
that into these conversations as well to make sure we're
aligned in what we're trying to achieve together as developer and
city and make sure that we're, we're doing it the right way.
So. Well, Sorry, one last question that just came into my mind.
Will these properties all have— I noticed that they're all
average acre lot or acre and a half?
Half acre. Oh, half acre.
Okay. Some of these will have animal
rights or no? No. No, this will be more like an arrival kind
of— No, much— it can have a minimum of a quarter,
maximum of 3 quarters, with an average of a So a lot of these are
quarters because of that average. So that's what the foothill is.
Is that eligible for an equine overlay though? No, not— it has to be half
minimum. That's what I'm saying. If they have a half acre, they're eligible to apply
for that, right? If they have equine overlay, they couldn't have those
rights. I'm assuming that's what you're referencing, the animal rights, because anybody can have
a dog or a cat or a little household pet. If we're talking about things
like livestock, livestock, horses and stuff, then, then they're— that would be in play.
Is it? So the— I mean, I understand that it has to be a half
acre, so would this be applied specifically to those lots that meet that
requirement? Correct. Okay. I thought that was
a— it was in an area where they were all half acre, because putting an
overlay on a specific spot zone with a quarter acre next to
it, I mean, that would be, you know, a policy decision. But look, I think
we I think we have to back up from that because from my perspective,
this is already zoned foothill residential. There's no overlay
in place. If the landowner wants to request that, that's certainly something
we could entertain. It's something that's available to them, Brett. If it's a half acre,
they can ask for an overlay. I understand that, but I'm not hearing him ask
for that. He's not, but I'm saying that an individual landowner
can ask for that because it meets the qualification of a half acre. That was
the question. So other question, this is for staff.
We don't have a current wildlife biologist on staff.
Who's performing those services for us? Are we reaching to other
agencies to have them evaluate our applications until
that decision's been made? As far as I know— and Brandon, if you can speak
up, or Steve— right now we're not. We don't— again, we don't— you said we
don't have a biologist on staff now. I don't believe any of these are being—
So I'm going to, I'm going to make the suggestion that that still needs to
happen even though we don't have somebody on staff. There are other agencies that provide
those services or outside consultants. We, we can't just not do it, especially when
we know that it's in the corridor. I think that that's something that needs to
be part of the process until that decision has been made. It still needs to
be evaluated. Yeah, Mayor, this is
Greg. We,
we had a little bit of discussion late last week about this corridor,
and I, I did bring that up. We're trying to track these things
and trying to bring this to the attention, and it's just a timing thing.
Um, I agree that we need to look at all this regionally because
the other thing that I'm going to add to the record with this as well
is with these washes, the way that they flow, like, we're not seeing
flow in them this year, but I think we need to be thinking about Ponds
higher up above these areas so that we
can dictate flow. So I just want to add
that to the record, and we need to be looking at all of these things
and how they tie and coordinate so that we can get on top of them
so we don't continue to run into the same issues that we've had in the
past. So have we been thorough on
this? And, um, no. Um, but we did have
a discussion towards the end of last week We did talk about some of these
scenarios. We did talk about that we probably need to get some feedback
from the Alliance and get them involved because they do have
some— they do know what was going on because they were working really close with
Todd during the process. So that's what we've been doing.
And we need to do a little bit better and try to do a little
bit better. Brad, just a— this is Rich.
Just a quick question then with regards to Past
flows that have come through this area. When you're evaluating
that, and maybe Vince is the person to answer this question, so if it is
Vince, then jump in. Are we evaluating?
I mean, you have to do a SWIP on this anyway, right? We're going to
have to take a look at how the water drains and where it runs,
whether or not the ponds that they have are sufficient. Do we use historical
data to help us to determine the size? that it needs to be based on
previous water flows? Yeah, that's correct. As far
as the development goes, they'll, they'll size for their internal,
but where we have a wash coming through, it's a completely different case. And as
a city, I think it's our responsibility to kind of master plan that and look
at the wash itself. So that probably needs to be something
that's in consideration, even though we're at a concept stage.
Maybe it's not big enough. We know we've had flooding in this area in the
past. What we don't want to see is that same thing that's happened in some
of our other areas that are downstream from this, where it continually floods
the same homes over and over again because of that natural
wash flow. So I just want to make sure as we're talking about
this, it's easy to look at things in a flat map
kind of way, but there are other things besides, you know,
the wildlife corridor and even the wash. It's Is it
following that exact wash? Is it coming into a plain and flooding the entire
plain? And what are we going to do to make sure that these homes aren't
impacted in the future by that? And, and just so you
know, those new culverts were installed, so you're actually in inlet control
mode for this wash. So the wash can only handle
the capacity that is in the culvert. So you, you actually
know your flow right now because Because it had to be sized
for the culverts that you put in in the Airport Road and
up on— what's it called— Harmony or something like that.
So you actually know the flow through my section because
it's controlled by your culvert sizing already. Did we upsize
these so we don't have the same Bell Street problem?
We did upsize it, yeah, and we took the culverts out of Bell Street.
And so yeah, it's a better condition than it was. I was kind of referring
to that because we've been down this road before, just one more road over.
So thanks. Okay, I was just going to
say, when I mentioned ponds in this area, I'm not thinking the pond needs to
go right in the middle of the development, but I think we need to do
a better job as a city at looking at the upstream checks as those
flow down so that we can make sure that we can mitigate those flows Whether
or not it's capacity or whatnot, because,
you know, most years we're going to be good, but it's that one year that
we, we have significant runoff like we've seen in the past that
we're going to have a problem. So we just need to make sure that we're
looking for it.
Perfect. So one other clarity that I wanted to make
a minute ago, this city portion up here is not part of the rezone.
Is that true or not true? It's under a previous
MDA, and that does have the equine overlay, as mentioned earlier.
None of this does. And, uh,
but this section right here would under an MDA. But what's the zone?
Is that— Yeah, it's Tier 2, I believe. It's, it's half— again,
half-acre minimum, equine rights. And I know there's probably a mechanism,
Marcus, you'd have to jump in, how that can be withdrawn
from Clearview or developed just as Clearview.
I mean, so we own the property. We could just,
you know, remove that development agreement from the property we
own unilaterally. We just do it by resolution.
You know, if we're— if we were contemplating, you know,
selling it, it'd probably be easier to to do a development agreement
with Ivory and then just amend and restate
those, you know, clarify in the development agreement that they're no longer subject
to that prior development agreement. That would be probably the easy button if we're inclined
to sell them. If not, then it doesn't really matter because it's our property and
we can change it anytime when we know what we're going to do with it.
So I just want to make sure that everyone understood that that needs a rezone
or a something as we move forward. So then,
not seeing anybody else that has any specific questions,
being a concept plan and knowing that we gotta move on a little bit,
do you feel like, does anybody know, feel comfortable
with where this is at? Do you know what's being asked? We're gonna meet.
Or are we holding off? I thought we were meeting
on the other stuff, the areas. Does this need
to be, Well, wasn't there the thought of meeting with
the council 2 at a time? And that's where we're at, so we know.
Okay. That would probably be the next step, would be to do that.
Okay, I just wanted to make sure that Brad had clear expectations
and that we didn't leave something hanging. And do I schedule that, or do
I want Dave to schedule that? Lacey, do you schedule the councils? The councils takes
care of their own. Okay, so I think,
uh, yeah, reach out one at a time and they can pair up
however they'd like, but no more than 2 together. Please do
it by Teams for me. Yeah, it's a lot easier
for me. You don't want me to see you face to face? Work is my
issue, so I'm not, I'm not available to do that. So if you can do
it by Teams, that's a lot easier for me to work. That's great. Thanks.
Okay, is there any other questions or do you have any other comments that we
need to go over at this time? No. Okay, thank you. I forgot
to mention earlier that item 1F is going to be postponed. It's going to
be held off. It wasn't ready. So Robert Hobbs is going to bring that,
I believe, on the 2nd. We should see that again.
So we'll move on to item 1G, which is the Utility Billing Water
Assistance Program, and our City Treasurer, Aaron Aaron has
this one. Should be fairly simple.
Easy peasy. This can be an easy one. Should be.
Good afternoon, Council Mayor. So this is regarding our
utility assistance program where the funds are already allocated to use.
We have approximately $15,000 that is left that
we can use by the end of December. What we're just
proposing is to expand the program so it can reach more of the city,
and then also just a little bit wider base of what it's going to cover.
Currently, um, it's only homeowners that are eligible.
We're looking to expand that to renters as well. And then
currently it is 50% of the
water basin usage, um, up to $75
per month. And it would be a maximum of 3 months that
they would be eligible according to restrictions
on the program. We're looking to change that to just 50% of
the utility bill up to $75, and then it still has the same
restriction of 3 months that we can offer it. So we're just looking for consensus
if you're okay with that, if you have any other feedback.
Just one question. If we went to the 50%, What if that
doesn't cover the entire water bill? Could it still be shut off, and some
of the other services could be shut off even though we've covered 50% of it?
So it— when we allocate it,
it always goes towards the water first when we're
applying, as far as it goes to fees, and then it goes to water,
and then beyond there it pays other services. So it's how we
allocate it. It would be whatever's left over to pay for the rest
Okay, thanks. Any other questions?
If we keep the limitation of 3 months,
are there people that are going to need services well beyond
that 3 months? Is that your experience? So the
3 months is a HUD requirement. We cannot provide beyond that
in a calendar year. But there's also funds like the
HEAT program program and some of those other ones that can step in after the
3 months. This is like a temporary assistance kind of a thing. So that would
be for other utilities. This is only for the city
utilities, so water, sewer, garbage is what this would cover.
It doesn't cover anything beyond that.
So power, they have their own program.
Do, do we foresee a time where this will be funded
from an additional fund, perhaps like affordable housing
or something like that, or donations?
Like, the limitation is specifically because of Community
Development Block Grant funds, but is there
a chance that there would be additional funding coming from a different
stream at some point? That's something that we could have Kiara look at to see
if we can obtain funding elsewhere. This is just
regarding what we've already been allocated for the 2025-2026 year that
we have to use up by the end of December. Awesome, thank you.
We're good? Looks like we're good and everybody agrees to move forward with this
one. All right, thank you. Thank you very much.
All right, um, next item, number 2. Uh, do you have any items?
Sure, I'll just mention a few things really quick. Um, just want to extend
appreciation to the elected leaders that participated in the Central Utah Water Planning
meeting that kicked off. We're trying to bring more water resources into our community,
and our elected leaders being dedicated to come to those meetings, as well as another
one coming up with USU and planning for more water-wise
landscaping and water, you know,
improving our design requirements, whatnot. So We appreciate you and
the staff that's involved in that. We also appreciate the council for
being involved in the neighborhood meetings. We had a good one this past week,
a very lively one with a great turnout, over 80.
And, uh, and so, um, we love the fact that you're getting out amongst
the people and, and, and getting some really good
communications going back and forth. We have many events and programs
that are in planning and going on right now. Those will be talked about in
the next meeting. Um, we also have the
Utah County Sheriff's Department is going to be honoring, uh, those, uh,
who have served so well this past year, uh, this coming week.
Um, of course, we're working really hard on the budget and getting everything ready for
the council's consideration there. Many of our projects are kicking off
and working, um, and moving forward. We had some delays, uh, with some
of the road projects due to the weather, um, but our water projects and other
things are moving forward really well. And, um, and then,
uh, lastly, uh, just to give the council a little bit of a heads up,
we did have some success this past week with
our assistant to the city manager who presented to our,
um, to the county with regard to our observatory.
And, um, while nothing's public yet,
the county is consider— is putting in contributing money to
that project now, and so they will be a contributing sponsor as well. Still have
a little bit of a shortfall, but we're, we're moving forward and good things are
happening there. Is the amount that the county is going to contribute equal to the
amphitheater contribution they're making to Provo? No.
Okay, thanks. I, I actually
forgot to report back on that. I think it was Thursday we talked, and I
did put some pressure on the county, and then apparently they They replied, so yeah,
it's good. They, uh, I said just give us a number. So,
Mayor, can I ask just a quick question? I'm wondering if, if it would be—
I was talking to John Magnus earlier, and I was wondering if it would be—
if we'd be able to get him to come participate in that water summit that's
happening in Heber the 2nd, 3rd of June. I just feel like
he would be a real asset there. Yeah, we can— if we can get him
registered and bring him along. I, I, I mean, I didn't really He wasn't on
the invite and wasn't planning. And I asked him and I said, boy, I think
we need you there. I don't know how everyone else feels about that.
We'll put that invitation out. If we could do it, that'd be great.
And I was just— you mentioned the lively meeting that we had on the— over
by the Ranches Boulevard without mentioning David, who took 90%
of the arrows. So he's, uh, I don't even know
that he's here. Oh no, he's not here today. He's still recovering.
Uh, but he did a stellar job too. So thanks, thanks for, uh, staff for
being there too and, and really taking the charge on that.
Um, we need to go through some of the consent items
the best we can, and I, I don't think it'll be too difficult. I do
want to mention that item 14A that is going
to be on the consent is here only for a correction. We, we had
a mistake from earlier, and there's yet another correction. So if we can fix
fix that in the motion. Just as a note, it says the fiscal year 2026
through 2029, I believe, in the packet, and it should be to reflect
2026 through 2027. So just make that, uh,
second correction, and then that one, that one should be good. But we
can go through those as we go. So, um,
we have a couple appointments. Just a reminder, it doesn't always have
to be this way, but the— I have as the liaisons
to— why did I lose it? I am.
It's— I believe it's Craig and Melissa for the Planning
Commission. No, Zach. Zach. So if you guys—
there's 2 appointments, and if you care to make those motions.
And then we have The
bond releases— had to get there.
Uh, Ochre Mountain out of warranty, and then Overland Village 2 out of warranty.
There's no questions. The minutes,
no corrections. Uh, the 14A is the resolution that I mentioned. We need
that correction. Um, is there any other questions on that one?
Easy. And then 14B resolution Um,
approving a memorandum of agreement with Ivory Homes. Mr. Draper?
Yeah, so this originally came before the council back in April.
Um, it included Citla as a party. The only change between
it is removing Citla as a party. That's the only change that's being sought.
The prior one was approved, um, but not executed
because Citla did not want to executed. I have
a general question about this. I sent you the email.
So that contract, that MOA, is not in effect because one of the
parties didn't agree to it, is that correct? The memorandum of agreement is not
in effect, correct? Correct. It was approved by the city council but was not executed
because Sitla was not willing to execute. And now we're doing a new MOA that
is just a single party. It was between us and Ivory.
Yes, there was a single other party, correct. Okay, so we're not reapproving,
we're looking at a new one that's with a single party? It's identical
in every other respect, but yes, it would be a new authorization because it's
substantively changed. Okay, so I
understand that part of it. Now I have some questions 'cause I didn't vote on
the first one. You did make the motion. I don't think I
voted on this one, did I? You did. I watched the video, I was watching
it for some other reason, that occurred in
the same meeting, and I noticed that you actually made the motion. Well, I didn't
pay attention to this one part apparently. Do we feel okay about giving less
water per unit?
It's— I mean, that's a may, right? It's a may,
but are we comfortable with that? That's one of the things I wanted to ask
the council before we go and approve this again. I didn't
catch that the last time around. Maybe that I didn't that wasn't on my radar
at the time, but I just wanted to ask that question. Councilmember Widdow, I mean,
I'll speak to that.
And maybe it's something that we should probably address in
a closed session at some point. But what I will say is this,
that I
think we need to be willing to to review
from time to time the water that we are requiring
for each type of development and just make sure that we are
contemplative of what the actual water use is.
And I think that that's what this May does, is it opens
up that discussion so that we can, we can actually look at
it with this developer in particular. And I think citywide we need
that we need to be at least aware of that and cognizant of that and
updating that from time to time as, as we see fit.
That's probably what I'll say. Just one last
question, uh, maybe just— I'm posing this to the council.
Understand that in E, each of these things are may's.
However, we've dealt with some may's in the past that then became shall's because
the understanding is that we were going to go forward with that. So before that
goes goes forward with a yes, just understand that even though it says may,
the inference is that they're looking for that horse trading to happen.
So I just want to make sure that that's clear. And oh, I was
just going to ask, and does this require
them to use the current architectural standards versus—
It references it. What was approved? It references it. Says that
they will Let's see, or that's a may as well.
It's in D that they will construct
higher quality architectural treatments for multifamily residential buildings located adjacent to the
future City Hall site to complete and complement the city's vision for
a Market Street environment with specific standards, materials, elevations.
Marcus, my question is, what, what is the city losing by removing Sitla from this
agreement? Mr. Wilk? You know, I would say that
the problematic part of Sitla not being part of
the agreement is in reference to the middle school site,
'cause that's really the part that affects Sitla.
And whereas the way that it's written, it's not super binding,
but we are committing to negotiate in good faith.
some loss of their, you know,
entering into an agreement to, you know,
negotiate in good faith in the future regarding that issue.
Doesn't mean they won't negotiate in good faith. They're just not signing
a document because of,
my understanding is time restrictions and actually sending it through their board for approval
and all that is the reason why they wanted it to be removed. Okay.
That's the big loss in my mind. The rest of it I think is mostly
things that are related to Ivory, and they are a signatory.
I, I hesitate to remove SITLA from this agreement based
on their timelines because we've got timelines, and we also have a responsibility to the
citizens of our city to make sure we're doing good agreements.
Yeah, I mean, that's the, the risk certainly, is if SITLA doesn't
if we can, you know, that's the risk.
That's, I guess, that's the way I'll put it. Uh, just one last question with
regards to that. That, that was the last question I had about the location of
this. Are we— is this MOA a specific location?
Is it the surrounding area around City Hall? Because it's
not really specific about where this exists, uh, and the 35-acre
parcel, it's not specific where that might Um,
this, this MOA is not specific to that, so there's flexibility
as to where the specific location— I know location ideas have
been discussed, but this would not be binding those specific locations.
Okay, last question. Uh, why would we have
interest in securing a lot for a middle school when that is the
responsibility of the school district? Um, so we have an obligation
to provide a 10-acre site that was presumptively for an elementary.
I understand what you're saying. Okay, so that's what it's in relation to. Thanks.
So do
you have a question? Okay, I just wanted to make sure that we're good on
that one, and it, it appears that there might be some need for Any further
discussion? Yeah, I think we need to pull it off and talk about it in
our policy session. Okay, just wanted to make sure I knew where we were at,
if there was more. Okay, uh, the next one is
14C. Make sure I didn't lose my place. This one's a resolution
of Eagle Mountain City initiating the city's withdrawal from United
Fire Service Area. I can say that
I was in the UFA meeting this morning and this came up.
Specifically with the budget. I have a lot of
maybe answers if there's questions. Chief Fossum is also here
to address this one. He does need to be excused later, so if we can
get through what we need to on this one, it would really help him out,
even though job comes first, right? But if
there are any other questions on this, I'm happy to answer.
I just think one of the things we just want to make clear to this
citizens that we're not getting rid of UFA. I think that that needs to be
clear, that we're removing the taxing entity of the UFSA and
contracting directly with UFA like other cities are.
Well, I, I would, I would caveat that with— and Ben has some information as
well, we were looking over the email that came in literally as we were walking
in here— that that would be our intent, but we don't currently have
a contract. So yeah, pending— This would simply initiate
that process. Yeah, thank you. That's the words I was
looking for, just so it's clear what the intent is, that we're not firing UFA,
we're initiating a process to contract directly, to adjust
our agreement. Yeah, this is strictly with UFSA, to leave UFSA and to start
over. So any questions for Chief Fossum?
Do we want to just make the statement that the purpose of that is then
we're getting the services we're paying for, we're not paying for other people's services.
I'll say that. That's my intent with it.
Nobody else is comfortable with that, I'll say it.
Did you have anything to add? No other questions? And that one's
okay where it's at? Perfect for you.
Um, the rest is all our scheduled items. We, uh, do have some updates on
some legal stuff. If the— there's only 2—
one public hearing and one ordinance that should be fairly simple.
Is there any need to go— Just, I just have one question.
I don't know if this is a Brett question or, uh,
Fossum or maybe Marcus. I understand
the 4-item, um,
the— Really? Yes, that. What is
that, 15A? 15A. 15A. So I understand the
the law that's requiring there to be a buffer zone,
right? Is there any onus on the adjacent owner?
So the development gets completed and now we're going right to
the property line. Does the adjacent owner that has
not developed, do they have any responsibility for a buffer on
their property? That was
one of the questions I had when the law was written. I think it's very
clear with the residential developers that they have a requirement as they develop
it that there's supposed to be a buffer. That's also to help with insurance for
the individuals that will own those homes. But what about the land
that is adjacent to that buffer zone? Do they have
a requirement for a buffer zone to the developed land?
I think the— if I understand it, and this came up in our meetings up
there, the buffer's from the structure. So it's 30 feet from the house.
So if there's no house on the adjacent property, there would be nothing to buffer
from. Is that the question on buffering?
And it's a property line, I thought.
Yeah, it's a property line buffer. From what
I said, you can step up here if you'd like.
We talked about it today in our meeting, and I'm pretty sure it's the structure.
It was 30 feet from the structure, is my recollection. And a lot of
those are— it's wildland, so it could be BLM, it could be National Forest
Service. But it also might not be. It could be an individual
landowner. So it would apply— it's a
structure setback from— so the way that it's written is saying,
you know, a WUI boundary lot is a lot that is within the wildland urban
interface area that's adopted on the map.
Okay? where the applicability would occur. And so,
the WUI adjacent setback means the applicable setback
on a boundary lot on this, what I just said. So, it's anywhere in that
WUI area on the adopted map for a primary or accessory structure for
property lines partially or fully abutting land described in
the definition of a boundary lot. So, it's land that
contains certain features that land that is outside
of city limits that is not subject, that's not developed,
and land that's owned by STITLA or the feds or some other
governmental entity. As a practical matter, those would be the— it'd
be, you know, BLM or STITLA. So those
are kind of like where the— I mean, I see that Beth really wants to
chime in here, but— Yeah. Yeah, I mean, that's what we're talking
about is where these would apply to somewhere within that that contains those features,
then you have this setback requirement from the property line.
My question was more general about the state law, because I, I feel like— I
mean, this is maybe something that needs to be talked with our state representatives.
It— I understand the, the ability
to be able to fight the fires and to prevent structure fires, but also,
I mean, all that onus is going on to people who have houses there,
that somebody's land that doesn't have a fire barrier can
absolutely move right up to them because there isn't anything preventing that
from getting there. I just, to me it seems like there needs to be a
shared ownership there. And obviously it doesn't, that doesn't exist in state code.
Yeah, this is not, I don't, my understanding is not a state code specific
requirement. It's a best practice requirement. Yeah, I understand that part of it.
Thanks, you answered my question. Okay.
I guess my question is just this. I mean, and staff alludes to
this. This is a step over and above what the state requires.
And so I'm just curious why.
You know, it's a discussion that we probably need to have.
I'm just— and maybe staff can answer that. I know, Beth, that you probably did
some work on this. I'm curious why we feel like we ought to consider this,
because I'm having a hard time saying if the state's requiring us to do X
and they're newly implementing this and we're compliant with that,
why are we taking it to the next step? That's what I'm trying to really
understand. And what's the onerous that we're putting on our citizens by doing so?
This is a— it's a proposal. It's— we're not— I
think we're bringing this to you fairly lightly, but It was recommended to
us from the RUFA. So that's what
I'm trying to understand, Brandon, is what's the intent of this? Yeah, it came— we
received a recommendation from RUFA to do this,
so. Okay.
What does this do to existing structures then that are already there?
Are they required to remove those structures? It's a zoning
ordinance. So it would be a nonconforming use,
or nonconforming, noncompliant structure. So, I mean, as long as
they maintain it, then great, they're nonconforming. If,
you know, they were to— they can't enlarge the nonconformity,
they just can maintain it.
I was just gonna say, this is all in the presentation that I'll present
to you and address and explain. Policy session. Yeah, because it is
a public hearing, I don't— I'm just curious if there's any specific questions,
but, uh, we'll, we'll wait for that for the policy session as
well as the flagship agreement.
Is there anything that we need to go over now on that, or should it
wait? Okay, um,
I think that is everything for the work
session. So I mentioned that we do have some updates from some
of our legal updates and other things to talk about if you're interested.
Mayor, I move to adjourn to a closed session pursuant to
Section 52-4-205, subsection 1 of the Utah Code Annotated.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a
second by Councilmember Wood, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes.
Councilmember Clark? Yes.
Yes. Okay, that passes. We'll adjourn to closed session
at 5:57.
As, as is our tradition, we're going to start with the opening prayer, and Rich
Woods offered that. Our Father
in Heaven, we're grateful to be together as citizens, elected officials, and staff
members of Eagle Mountain City. We pray that thy spirit might rest
upon us, help us to be contemplative of the
decisions that we're making, to listen to each other, to think
of the future as we make these decisions.
To be able to alliterate the reasons that we are making the decisions,
we're grateful for the people who make up our city,
for the community that they have created and that we are a
part of. We pray that that would watch over and protect each of them.
We're thankful for our first responders. We pray that that would continue to watch over
and protect them as they protect us. Please watch
over our military. Particularly those that are in harm's way.
Keep them safe where possible. We're grateful for the
good country that we live in as we celebrate the 250 years and the
circumstances and the sacrifices that have been made to give us the freedom
that is sought after by the rest of the world. Pray that
we will be good stewards of that freedom, that we will remember
the importance of being involved as citizens,
doing our civic duty both at the municipal level
and at the county, state, and federal level as well, and to let our
representatives know what we would have them do. And we say these things in the
name of Jesus Christ. Amen.
All right, thank you. We'll go ahead and call this meeting to order now at
7:10, uh, policy session of the Eagle Mountain City Council on Tuesday the
19th. And we will begin with the Pledge of Allegiance,
and Cadence Hornson is going to help lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Repeat after me. I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America and to the republic for
which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for
all. Indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Okay, thank you, Cadence. Um,
come back here and I got to get all my stuff ready to go.
We will begin with
some— is Don here? Don was
here. Don's here with some information items from Don.
This is, uh, leading up to the events of the week.
Um, tons of stuff. This is our last meeting before all chaos.
Yes, it is. Um, first up, I have some information items for—
from Ben. Um, the library will be closed on Saturday,
May 23rd, and Monday, May 25th. Um,
and then just a reminder that Eagle Mountain residents can receive 2 free landfill
passes each year, and they can be picked up at the customer service desk
here inside City Hall. Okay,
um, Pony Express Days is May 25th through
June 13th. I'm just going to read off the event and the day
and time, and if there's any follow-up questions as to what the event is,
you guys can ask me after. Uh, May 25th will start with the Memorial
Day ceremony at 10:00 AM. Uh, May 27th is family
fun night, 4 to 8 PM at Nolan Park.
May 28th is the first night of the carnival, 4 to 10 PM at
Ride Memorial Park. May 29th and 30th are full
days of the carnival, um, and that starts at noon and ends
at 11 PM. May 30th is our grand
parade, and Jim Smith is our grand marshal
this year. Um, May 30th we will also
have a car show from 4 to 7 PM at Mid Valley Field.
May 30th is also the fireworks, um, at 10 PM,
Ride Memorial Park. May 27th through 29th,
we have a pickleball tournament at Quarry Ride Park.
There's a lot packed into Phoenix Thursdays this year. June 1st
is our first annual Guns and Hoses pickleball tournament.
That's our UFA against our Sheriff Department,
um, so it'll be super fun. 6 PM Memorial Park.
June 5th, um, we will have a Pony Express Days movie
in the park. June 6th, we'll be doing a street hockey tournament.
June 6th, um, we'll do the Motivational Mile with Ben Lyon
from 1 to 4 PM. June 6th is
also the kickoff of our farmers market at 9 AM.
June 6th is also the demolition derby, 7 PM.
Pony Express Express Rodeo Grounds. June 11th
through 13th is the PRCA Rodeo, 7 PM,
Pony Express Rodeo Grounds. Okay, any questions
on Pony Express Days? Just one clarification. The first event,
the Memorial Day, you didn't give a location.
Oh, sorry about that. That is at Pony Express Memorial Ceremony—
Cemetery. I wanted you to add because a lot of those have registrations like
the pickleball and then tickets and stuff like that. Do you want to— I know
you start to go way back to the top, but which ones that you know
of need tickets and where can they get them? Um, so tickets
you'll need for the carnival, obviously, if you want to participate in that,
you can get it at our city website. Um, and all of the registration links
for all of these are on our city website. So the pickleball tournaments, you'll need
to register for any of the sporting events. Um, everything else
is Just free to attend. Is that all under the events site?
It is. Yeah. Yep. There's a Pony Express Days tab on the website.
All of the information and registration links are there. So,
Mayor, what I heard Dawn say is she doesn't have anything to do between now
and the middle of June. I don't. So if there's anything else you'd like me
to add, just throw it at me. Thank you for— We're not busy at all.
Just one other thing too, with the derby and the Pony Express rodeo,
you'll have to go to Pony Express events to buy those tickets?
Yes, there is also, I believe, on our city website a link to
their website to purchase the tickets as well.
So that's all of Pony Express Days. Anything else for Pony Express Days? Any other
questions? Holy smokes, do you need help? Lots of help.
Parade, mostly the parade. Are you asking for volunteers for these? We are,
especially the parade. Any help that we can get
along the parade route, people can reach out to us at events@eaglemountain.gov.
We can get them signed up to help us. Um, I think that would be
great if we could put that information onto our website and social media so that
people know we're looking. Yeah. And where they can get a hold of you to
do that, because I think we'll get a lot of people show up. Okay,
I'll have them post that for us. Um,
okay, outside of Pony Express Days, I just wanted to talk about a couple other
upcoming events, um, that are
following Pony Express Days, just for it to be on your guys's radar. So the
food truck rallies will start, um, the first Thursday in June, and they
go every Thursday until the end of August from 6 to 9 PM
at Ride Memorial Park. Um, and then we'll have our Fourth of July fireworks
on July 4th. The event will kick off at 8 PM, and we're
leaning heavy into the America 250 theme, so it should be a super, super fun
event. And then our Summer Bash and laser show July 25th
from 4 to 10:15 PM, again with the America 250 theme
for those. So have a lot to look forward to this summer.
Man, it's gonna be fun. It is. You have questions? And Ben, I assume that
covered everything, right? You had heard? Good. Not as great
as Ben at reading it off, but— All right,
sweet. Thanks, everyone. All right. I wanted to point
out this for those of you who have never been to a queen contest,
that you notice all these pretty ladies in the front row and how they sit.
How many of them have their phones out? None. And they have their hands
like beautifully placed on their legs and like absolutely
amazing. That's how they sit for like 6 hours during the contest without
moving. It's amazing. So with us tonight, we have
the newly crowned Pony Express Breast Days royalty,
and I'm gonna let them introduce themselves, starting with the queen and the attendants,
and then the princess court. I think Angie would
have to correct me. Angie's our queen mom. I didn't call you queen bee.
So, um, she— is this our youngest
princess we've ever had in the, in the court at 8,
right? Yes. So we're pretty excited to, to welcome our
royalty. You guys can step up and Go ahead and introduce us— introduce yourself to
Okay, um, my name is Kayden Sorensen.
I'm your 2026 Pony Express Rodeo Queen. Um, I'm from
American Fork, Utah. I used to live in Eagle Mountain though, so Eagle Mountain is
kind of home to me. And yeah, we're just here to invite you all to
the Pony Express Rodeo, June 11th through the 13th, like Don said earlier,
and then also the demolition Derby, which is June 6th.
I'm Camilla Sylvester. I'm your guys's 20— uh, the second attendant this year,
and I'm so excited to be here. And, and yeah, just a second what Cadence
said, just, um, the rodeo is going to be so much fun this year,
so we're excited if you guys come.
I'm Lydia Knapp. I'm the first attendant, and I'm
from Lyndon, Utah. I have served in the royalty before,
and I love it here in Eagle Mountain and I'm excited for this year.
Hello, I'm Kelsey Bowen, your Pony Express Rodeo Royalty Princess.
I am locally from Eagle Mountain, Utah, and I'm just
so excited to serve this community as my first time ever competing. Thank you.
I'm Nicole Anacleto, your first attendant as a princess. I'm originally from
Eagle Mountain, Utah, and I speak fluent Portuguese.
I'm Whitney, and I'm
second attendant. Good job,
Whitney. Okay, you guys come back up here because we're gonna do something.
I'm gonna orchestrate this for a picture. So queen and princess right
here, then the attendants on that side and the attendants on this side for the
princess, and then we're gonna stand up and take Just
make sure everyone has a window so like you can see the camera, because otherwise
I can't see you. Just, just so you know. Yeah,
dip down just a little bit, Lydia. There you go.
Stand on your tiptoes, Jared. All right.
Thank you. In the
past, you guys have asked questions or made comments. I'm just asking if anybody have
anything you want to add or we good to move on? Just wanted to make
sure you had a chance. Okay, um,
we will move on. Thank you, ladies. The next
item is public comment. So we
will open the public comment period. Just so you know, there's forms in the back
in that blue folder. If you haven't filled one out, you can, and you can
make your comments that way. So I will now open the public comment period at
7:20. As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for community members to address
the City Council, and each speaker is allowed up to 3 minutes.
If you wish to speak during the public hearing portion,
Please complete the comment form located in the back and return it to the city
recorder. Council members will listen but not engage in a discussion
during public comment. Disruptive behavior, personal attacks, or comments
about individual city employees are not permitted. If you have
issues or questions regarding staff or personnel, administrative staff will meet you in the foyer
to discuss that. And if that's the case, Steve, we'll meet you in
the foyer. Lastly, public comment period is for items not associated
with a scheduled public hearing. If your comment relates to a public hearing item,
please wait until that item is called. Today's public hearing is item
15A, and it's an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending the
Municipal Code 1710.030. So if that's
the item that you're here to comment on, hold your comment
until that item is called. All other comments will be heard at this time,
and we'll look to Lacey. David Peterson.
Hi, my name is Dave Peterson. I live in the Silver Lake area
of Eagle Mountain, and I just wanted to voice my support
for a road from the Silver Lake area to the new high school.
And also just want to thank all of you for your service.
I know it's sometimes thankless, but I wanted to let you guys know how much
we appreciate your time and let you know my feelings on that. So thank you.
Thank you, David. Robert Woodward.
Hey, I'm Robert Woodward. Uh, just to kind of mirror what Dave said,
again from Silver Lake area, and all of
us over there, the more that you speak to us, you'll probably understand we all
support that road. We We need it badly. It's been discussed that we need a
study. We don't need a study. We need a road. We can do a study
if we need a roundabout or if we need a light or anything like that.
But the accident the other day on Pony
Express just proved the fact that there is no way in
and out of there. People were stuck for hours. It was a bad situation.
So please, please take that into account. Thank you.
really need that other emergency exit out of that neighborhood.
Scott Griffith.
My name is Scott Griffith. I also live in Silver Lake area.
I wrote mine down because I get angry
and frustrated if I don't write it down. And I stumble over
my words. So yeah, I'm from the Silver Lake area. I've been there for 6
years now. It's been fantastic. I love Eagle Mountain. I love everything about Eagle Mountain
except for the traffic, of course, like everybody else. But I
started an online petition on this Silver
Lake Parkway road that had 300 signatures in less than 2 days,
and it now has 445 signatures. of individuals just from
the South Silver Lake area. Currently, Pony Express serves as
the primary route in and out of Silver Lake, as it does for all of
Eagle Mountain. And creating
severe congestion during peak travel hours and leaving residents vulnerable to delays
of work, school, emergency services, and daily activities.
Completing Silver Lake Parkway to connect somehow with Mountain
View Corridor and the new and the road to the new high school would provide
a critical secondary access point for Silver Lake that would significantly
improve traffic flow, reduce travel times, and support the long-term mobility of our
small community. This need is becoming even
more urgent as many families and children are having, you know,
3 or 4 or 5 children, and all of those kids
are going to be driving age within the next 5 to 7 years,
and that might more than double the amount of cars
on the road. Additionally, without a connection to Saratoga, we would
likely be denied entry to the new high school in our own backyard by
the new school district. Equally important, the connection is a matter of public safety.
Like Mayor Gray said on ABC News yesterday, in the event of
a wildfire, major accident, natural disaster,
other emergency problems requiring evacuation.
Relying on a single primary exit for thousands of residents
and over 2,100 homes in the Silver Lake area just
isn't okay, in my opinion. A completed Silver Lake
Parkway would provide a reliable alternative evacuation,
improve emergency response times, and strengthen the overall resilience of
Eagle Mountain. Not just Silver Lake, but also for the nearby ranches
and other neighborhoods. Thank you. Investing in a connection
is not just about convenience. The steep incline on Pony Express into
Eagle Mountain could be entirely bypassed in the event of severe
weather. 30 seconds remaining. As motorists could take the long way out if their
car isn't safe for travel. And then number 2, I just wanted to mention there
needs to be a stop sign on Golden Eagle Road and Silver Creek Way.
I encourage all of you to go there during start and end times
for for the elementary school Brookhaven right there.
Um, a kid almost dies every day, and I don't think a kid should have
to die in order to put a stop sign in. And I don't think a,
uh, travel study or whatever needs to be done.
It just— it's dangerous and it's scary. Thank you. Your time is up.
Thank you.
That's all I have. Okay, that's all that's been turned in. Is there
anyone else here that came to make public comment?
Seeing no one, we'll close our public comment time at 7:26
and come back to our agenda. The first item on our agenda is
a fun one, item 10A, a Planning Commission appointment. We'll start
with number 1, separate motion, then number 2, and then we
can do the swearing in right after. So go
ahead. Mayor, I'll make a motion to appoint Chad DiCorsi for
a 1-year To fill the 1-year vacated term,
uh, going from May 2026 through March 2027.
Second. That's to approve the appointment for Chad DiCorsi?
Correct. We have a motion by Council
Member Hewish and a second by Council Member Clark,
and we'll start the vote with Council Member Clark. Yes.
Council Member Wright. Yes. Council Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member Wood. Yes.
And Council Member Hewish. Yes. All right, this, uh, number 2 appointment is
Laura Jensen for a 3-year term as the alternate from May
2026 through March 2029. So moved.
Perfect. We have a motion. Second. We have a motion by Council Member Clark.
I love it when you do that. And a mo— and a second by Council
Member Whiting. And we'll start the vote with Council Member Wright.
Yes. Council Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member Wood. Yes. Council Member Huish.
Yes. Councilmember Clark? Yes. Yes. Okay, perfect.
That— those motions both pass, and we'll invite the city recorder, Lacey Messerschmidt,
to administer the oath of office. My brain is faster than my tongue
today. And have you guys come up, and we'll join you on the side.
Go ahead
and raise your right hand. I, state your name. I, Chad Kirksey.
Do solemnly swear. Do solemnly swear. That I will support, obey,
and defend. That I will support, obey, and defend. The Constitution of
the United States. The Constitution of the United States. And the Constitution of the State
of Utah. And the Constitution of the State of Utah. And that I will discharge
the duties of my office. And that I've discharged the duties— And that I've discharged
the duties— Of my office with fidelity. Of my office with fidelity.
Same thing. I mean, it's not the Queen's, but come right here.
It's one of them.
All right, now we'll move along. Thank you guys for your willingness to serve.
I really appreciate that. Um, excited for the good recommendations we'll
get from the Planning Commission. We're going
to, uh, now's the time that we have set aside for the City Council
and mayor to make comments. Um, Melissa, you want to start
with the comments? Council Member Clark? Sure, I'd be happy to. Um,
I'm super excited to have a full Planning Commission again.
It's always hard when we don't have that I think our Planning Commission is
probably the most thankless job in our
city because they do almost as much preparation as we do
as city council members, and we're super grateful that you were
crazy enough to say yes. And also,
I had a really cool opportunity last week to go attend Cedar
Valley High School's Aviator Celebration of Excellence.
It stands— ACE is like the the acronym for it.
But it was really, really cool because as they're like announcing
all these kids and their really cool accomplishments, there was one girl
that had like probably 25 things that
she had accomplished. All these certificates, she got her associate's
degree. I mean, she was just stellar. And kid
after kid after kid, I was like, oh, I know that kid. I used to
be like their scout leader, you know, different things like that. And I was thinking
to myself, These kids grew up here. They started
kindergarten here in Eagle Mountain, and now they're graduating from our high school.
And it just really hit home with me how
the magnitude of the decisions that we make here at City Council
and how much those decisions impact the kids
and the people of our community. And I was thinking
about the fact that we're not just passing budgets, But we're creating a place
our children can be proud to call their hometown. And whether they
wear the colors of Cedar Valley High School or Westlake High School or
Rockwell High School, they have one thing in common:
that this place is theirs. And I
hope that as they go out into the real world and take
on the next big adventure, that they are proud to call this place. Place home
and that we can do them justice by the things that
we do here on City Council.
Thanks, Mayor. Welcome everyone, it's good to see you. Um,
thank you to the planning commissioners who have, who have now officially been appointed
and sworn in. Welcome to the fight. You'll know what that
means here shortly. I know, I know Chad's been involved in that, uh, in that
battle already, and we're just really grateful for you. Um, Pony Express
Days— I always love Pony Express Days, and I'm excited for that. The 4th of
July in particular always makes me smile. I had the
chance over the last 2 days to— in fact, this afternoon I, I went to
one. But I, I have 2 of my grandchildren. I have a grandchild who's graduating
from 6th grade and getting ready to go into the new middle school,
and, uh, not the new one, but the one here in City Center. And so
I've been to Mountain Trails Elementary And it's
a pretty interesting thing to be a public servant on the City Council and to
spend time in the community at some of the community events and at a school
in particular. Boy, there's just a truckload of kids and parents and
families and grandparents. And I'm just,
I'm just really appreciative of the teachers, the staff that work
there, and the tremendous work that they're doing with our students and with our kids.
And today I was, I was John Hancock. I've got a grandson who just
graduated from kindergarten, and I don't remember doing kindergarten
graduation when I was in kindergarten, or 6th grade graduation for that matter.
But I, I, my mind went back
as I sat there and listened to the things that he recited.
They had the Pledge of Allegiance. They have some things that they say in the
morning. And, and anyway, I was really moved by
by what they're being taught in those schools. And what
I remembered was going back to a council meeting where I
was really wrestling with whether or not John Hancock Charter School
should be placed where it's at. I'm still not sure it's in the right location.
I'm going to say that just to be official. But the fact
that we were able to get to a yes, and I really wrestled with getting
to that yes, and I know that other council members did as well.
But you fast forward a few years and you start to look at those impacts.
Those are the types of things that we're building. Those are the types of things
that you're building as community members. So thank you for your energy and your effort,
for your dedication, for your patience. Traffic is awful.
We know that. We're fighting the fight. Some days it
feels like we're going backwards, but most days we're actually making a small dent in
it and trying to, trying to move it in the right direction. I just love
Eagle Mountain. I love the people of Eagle Mountain. I love this
community, which is a very unique and robust
and a unique destination for families to come and
to live in a family-centric community. And I'm just grateful to each of you for
making it that.
2 days ago, there was an amazing rededication
of this country as a dedicated
land for, for God and God's purposes. And if
you did not listen to Speaker Mike Johnson's prayer that
he offered to rededicate this country, I encourage you to
look that up on YouTube and listen to that. It's about 10 minutes.
It will move you to tears and also remind us
who the founder of this country really is.
one nation under God. God set
up this country. He preserved it for numerous— like,
he preserved it for millennia for us
to now occupy it. And you got to think, well, if it was preserved for
that long, for what reasons did he preserve it?
And I would invite you just to take
the 10 minutes to listen to Mike Johnson's
prayer, Speaker Johnson's prayer, and then take another 10 minutes to share
with your family. It is very powerful and very moving.
I'll also read the scripture that President
Trump shared. He said,
and this is God talking about
the dedication of the Temple of Solomon that was God's
temple. If my people which are called by my name shall humble
themselves and pray and seek my face and turn from
their wicked ways, then will I hear from heaven and
will forgive their sins and will heal their land. And I
invite us to remember the,
the real founding father of this country, and then the founding fathers
and mothers that were inspired to help set this up.
I invite us to share these messages with our family so that they will remember.
And it really is about that. It's so easy in our day and age of
materialism to forget who set
this country up and for what purposes. And so I give
you that invitation.
Love seeing everybody here. I appreciate those who are here. I wish the
people from Silver Lake would have stayed. Um, I live there,
by the way. I'm very aware of the situation there. My kids
go to Brookhaven, and next year they'll go to Silver Lake.
Um, one of the things I think is important, and I want to
highlight a couple things— I was grateful that Jared,
our mayor, decided to meet with ABC and to kind of lay
out what we're trying to accomplish. One of the disappointing things I'm going to say
is that people jump so quickly to conclusions of nefariousness
about the people who are up here. And I want to dispel
that first and foremost. Nobody's benefiting financially
or otherwise by being here. In fact, it's the opposite.
The sacrifices that are made by the people who are your elected officials
is substantial, financially and otherwise, to be
here to represent the people of Eagle Mountain.
With regards to the discussions about roads,
There's no greater advocates for getting the roads fixed than the five people sitting
up here and our mayor. The reason Lake Mountain Corridor
even exists is because of the people sitting here,
and the fact that it's going to take eight to ten years has nothing to
do with us. That has to do with finances. I think it's funny
when people are like, "We'll just spend the money." You just, you know, take it
from here and put it here kind of a thing. And I think I would
encourage people to learn. Before we make statements like that, understand where the
money comes from, that there are limitations to how money can be
spent. And trust me, if there was a big pot of money that we could
take and build the road, it would already be built. We benefit individually,
our families benefit from having roads that get us in and out of the city.
And even to the, to the comments from the people who live in Silver
Lake with me, believe me, we want to have connectivity, but what we
don't want to do do is create problems that are bigger than what we are
already experiencing. That's the reason that we have the studies being done,
and we have to look at everything as a holistic picture,
from what Saratoga Springs is planning to do to the south of us,
whether or not that connection is the right connection, or if there are other connections.
We have to make those contemplative decisions, because if we don't
and everything's a knee-jerk and we act in the very moment because something
needs to be done right this moment, we set future generations up for
consequences that we could have avoided. And I just think it's important
for people to understand that we don't take these decisions lightly. We argue
a lot about these decisions in closed
doors, in one-on-ones, oftentimes to
get to the solution that is best. And if you think for a second that
we're, you know, just making these decisions lightly, it's— I'm going to
tell you, it's not. A lot of sleep has been lost. A lot of tempers
have flared, trying to decide how the best way to accomplish
these things for the for the citizens. And I just think it's so important to
highlight the work that is being done by the people
that you've elected. You can clear us all out in the next election if you
think that'll solve it, but I'm going to tell you that would be a mistake.
The people who are fighting for you right now is the best council that has
been in Eagle Mountain. I've been here thirteen years. They're pointed in the same direction,
and that is progress. We now have allies at
our county. We have allies in our surrounding cities.
We have allies at the state. That has not been the case ever,
and that's because there are individuals working collectively
for the same goals to try to make Eagle Mountain a safer place,
to get better egress and ingress into the city. And I just, I want to
say that. I want to be on the record saying that whoever wants to take
that and do whatever they want with it. I'm available for you to call if
you think that I'm crazy. Call me and tell me I'm crazy, but let's have
a one-on-one conversation. I'll produce the facts for you of why we make the decisions
that we make. Maybe that'll give you a better understanding of why we make the
decisions that we make. But I think we're all open to that very same thing.
Our telephone numbers are available. I'd rather you call me
than try to fight this out on Facebook because it doesn't seem like anybody's interested
in the truth there. So give me a call and I'll tell you the facts
that I know and why I make the decisions that I make. Thank you for
coming and being a part of the process. Those that are watching online,
get a hold of us. Then you don't have to wonder anymore. You can know
the truth about why we make the decisions. Thanks.
Thank you, fellow council members, and thank you everyone for coming
tonight for whatever purpose you're here— to learn, to observe.
I wanted to share a quote from a book that I read. It's by
Walter Isaacson. He's one of the great biographers
of our time. He's done biographies on Steve Jobs,
Elon Musk. He did one
on Michelangelo and—
was it Michelangelo? I think it was.
No, it was Leonardo. Sorry. And he did one on Benjamin Franklin.
And I wanted to share just a quick
quote that Benjamin Franklin said, that knowledge is obtained by the use of the ear
than of the tongue. And that's a good reminder.
We have been going on these listening tours to each neighborhood
around Eagle Mountain. I think I've been to 5 now. Somehow I've been able to
go to all of them with my fellow council members. And it's been a
really eye-opening experience to go to each community and just hear what the needs
are. Silver Lake wanting to connect to the high school and have
access to a road. Here recently we had one in Cason,
correct? Cason's neighborhood in Highlands on
Ranches Parkway. And I would just say that oftentimes
if we will just listen and ask questions, we become much better
informed, and that's really our goal with those. So as we celebrate our 250th,
in the world that we live in, I think it's a good practice for us
to learn to listen. As my mom would say, Zach, God gave you
2 ears and 1 mouth. And she was right.
So I'll go ahead and close with that. But I appreciate all of you being
here. Okay. Thank you. I just want to add a couple of
comments similar to what Councilmember Wood was touching
on. But on Thursday, I was sitting at a MAG meeting.
I think I was at roughly hour 17 or
18 on my day that day. Late— those, those meetings go late,
and I started UFA extra early. Literally looking
at the prioritization of our funding that some of our roads
in Eagle Mountain did not score high enough on to make the funding threshold.
I was less than pleased for
your enjoyment. And I let them know,
and I will guarantee you that I'm advocating for Eagle Mountain roads.
I think because of my just short of a tantrum
that some of our roads might get moved up into a funding category.
So I think to the ABC news
piece that ran yesterday, they did about a 5-minute interview
and picked about a 10-second clip. About 8
to 10 years. I didn't say that I was okay with 8 to 10 years.
What I said is that's not soon enough.
So I haven't had time to look, but I've heard that on Facebook,
you know, I'm not doing enough. I literally went on the news
to say we're not waiting 8 to 10 years. We're going to take
action. So just kind of an update that those things are happening.
All weekend I've been working on our roads. I've called the state leadership
to request a meeting. We're going to do our best to work
with them. They've invested a lot of money in our area. But we have to
have a resolution much sooner than what it
is right now. So I just wanted to report on that. As I mentioned,
we're sitting in MAG as within a 20-minute period—
and this I'm going to expand on— we had 5 calls within
20 minutes right behind 3 or 4 calls that had already happened,
with agencies responding as far as Pleasant Grove, American Fork,
Lehi with mutual aid. 5 calls within 20
minutes. Extrications, life flights,
search and rescue, not minor fender benders. And we
needed help from across the county. We can't do this any
longer. So With that, a huge appreciation, and I
know— I don't even know what cruise we're on, but all of UFA, all of
our first responders that are keeping us safe even
throughout the county, that we sure appreciate the effort that's put
in to keep us moving, even if it is at a slow pace right now.
And we're doing our best to
make sure that we can accelerate that timeline, and I'm not taking 8 years
for an answer. That will not work. So we will
take measures. I've been meeting with our attorney internally to see
what it is that we can do to best serve us. And we don't
know what that is yet, but we're working on those solutions. And I can promise
you it's not on deaf ears. I sit in this traffic too.
Just want to, on a lighter note, spend some time— I love spending time in
the schools. For years I got told I had never been inside a school.
School back during those discussions. Today and
last week, and I'm there all the time, I did a Shark Tank event with
the junior high. Super fun. We'll see
if we can get some of that out on social media. But I got a—
I told him I was like Simon Cowell. I'm not gonna be nice to these
kids. But I did buy 2 businesses, so I'm broke.
They had great pitches and it was kind of a math project
and we— they were doing bungee jumping Barbies, and it
was fun. So I got to sit next to Julie King and of course banter
with her like we always do. And, and I—
now I'm gonna go back to a more serious note because Julie was upset.
As I was leaving, one of the little kids came running up to me and
asked for my autograph. And it was, it was actually quite— she's
like, did you pay that kid? You set this up, something's going on. And then
we had this cool text thread, and I just wanted to say echo
kind of what my fellow council members said about the opportunity to serve at this
time. I sent her a message after I was done teasing,
and, you know, we always poke each other, and said, you know what, it's never
lost on me that nobody's looking for Jared Gray's autograph, not one
person. They're there looking for an autograph from the
mayor of Eagle Mountain. And that to me is a
big deal. To those kids, it's not— they're not looking for me. They're looking for
the mantle and the responsibilities
that we hold as elected officials. So that was pretty touching
for me, and I think that's important that we remember. I say it all the
time, it's not mine, it's just my turn. And it was quite an honor to
be able to represent the city in signing autographs.
So that was a lot of fun. But thanks.
So we've got to move on. Enough of that.
Let's, uh, go to item number 12. It's actually— actually,
all the items are consent agenda. This is the next thing on our thing.
And remember, there's some corrections on item 14, and I believe there was— I didn't
write them down, but, uh, one item that needed to be pulled possibly.
Okay, uh, would— I'd be happy to make a motion.
Okay, Mayor, I move that the city council approve the consent
agenda, um, updating a typo
in item 14A to state 2026
through 2027 and removing 14B
and placing it on the regularly scheduled items part of the agenda.
Second. Yeah, I think I got, uh,
Council Member Wright. So we got a motion from Council Member Clark and a second
from Council Member Wright, and we'll start the vote with Council Member
Whiting. Yes. Council Member Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hewish?
Yes. Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes.
Okay, with that, we will— the consent agenda passes,
and we will go to item 14B, which is— she
said B. Okay, it's a
resolution of Eagle Mountain City approving the memorandum of agreement with
Ivory Homes. Did I— yes, Brad stuck around.
So we went over this in the— at length in the
Work session. Do you, from the council's perspective, do we need Brad
up here? Do you need information from Marcus?
What's the— what are the questions?
Brad, you're welcome to come forward. I'm sure you're going to get asked questions.
I didn't know what they wanted, but I might as well just call you up.
So this is a memorandum that we've discussed at
length that had to do with the road exchange and Yeah, it's, uh, in relation
to the bypass road. There's, you know, various provisions
of sort of understandings that the parties have as to how we
want to proceed in the future on things and, uh, and what direction we
want to go. And so this would be, you know, an agreement to work
in good faith towards getting, you know, formalizing those issues.
I think I expressed earlier, and this is not a question but an expression,
I, I don't feel comfortable removing Citla from the agreement
based on the— So we, you know, after the
work session, I briefly spoke with Brad about the issue of the school
site, and he mentioned that they can just unilaterally purchase that
35-acre property from Citla per their agreement and
do a deal with the city directly on that. And so the memorandum— When
you say they, you mean Ivory? Ivory. Ivory could purchase from Sitla and then do
an exchange with the city. So, so maybe I could— I mean, chime in a
little bit. So maybe a part of the agreement is helpful. Yeah,
so our agreement is a lease agreement with Sitla.
The, um, Villages 1 through
8 are currently part of our lease agreement.
Um, any transaction, um, that we do in those 8
villages We conduct the business
and we purchase that from SITLA, and then
either we give them a percentage of the residential
sale, or in commercial uses, we split profits
one way or the other. And so
all the transactions happen through Ivory. So anything we do
with you on this, We would do the transaction,
and then we would get consent from Sitla before
we proceed with anything. If that makes sense, the Pony Express
parcel where we've talked about placing a
potential school site is an option parcel in our
lease agreement. So in order for us to work
with you on that site, we would have to
exercise our option to. take that piece and then work
with Sitla to purchase it and then do all of the other
horse trading ideas that we come up with. And that,
that is the purpose of this memorandum of understanding, is that
nothing's set in stone yet, but we will work towards
a solution that's equitable for everyone, meaning Ivory,
Sitla, and Eagle Mountain City. Thank you. Does that make sense?
So would it make you more comfortable— I don't know if this is even a
question— if they instead— it's a memorandum of understanding or of
agreement, right? Um, does it make you more comfortable if
it says they will? Right now it's kind of more of a good faith,
so I'm trying to get that a little stronger, that they will make that transaction
happen or facilitate that. Like, is it a verbiage thing?
No, I was— if CITLA had any obligation,
I didn't want that obligation removed. But if Ivory has a unilateral ability to
execute on CITLA's portion of the agreement,
then I feel better about that. Yeah, any agreement
we do in the future, we will have to get their consent on.
So we will work with you to come
up with the levers that we want to pull,
and then we will go take it to CITLA and get their Blessing
before we proceed on anything.
I've been pretty open about what I want removed. I don't want an
MOA that deals with water reduction requirements.
That doesn't mean that we can't negotiate that as part of an MTA agreement
or an amendment. I don't want to be obligated to it, though.
And I don't think this agreement does that. In my opinion, it was just a
list of— Then it doesn't matter if it's in there. That's, that's kind of my
point. If it doesn't matter, then it shouldn't be in there. I think it was
just nothing, nothing's in there that's concrete
though, right? These were just ideas that we could look
at to, in trade for the school site.
They weren't, they weren't concrete items. They were just potential things
to look at. That's my only— Brad, if take
that out of there, I don't have a problem with the rest of it.
I think we can act in good faith with all the other things, but water
is not one of those things I'm ready— I, I'm willing to horse trade with.
I was just thinking how in a lot of ways the things that are in
this memorandum of agreement are very similar to the
tools that we put in our toolbox that we can use with the wildlife
corridor. Not everybody's going to get all the things that we listed
in the code, that this could be a tool. But it's,
it's one of those things that a council has the ability to
use to get good outcomes.
But I am super sensitive to Council Member Woods'
concerns. I'm just wondering if there's some language
that we could change in the memorandum to make it so
that it's clear that it's just Just a potential tool and not a guaranteed
thing. I know that water's such a huge thing now,
and every developer on the planet is like, you need to do
this. So it's, it's hard when we do it
in good faith with one, because then the expectations are that
we will be able to do that with all the others, and it really
is very case by case. So I'm struggling with
that as well.
Would it make any difference to, to you 2 council members if
in, in E where it says city's considerations, we were
to modify the language? It says the city will consider providing benefits to the developer,
which may include, and then it lists some items there.
If that were to change to the city may consider providing
benefits to the developer, which may include— what
if we remove the word will? Okay. Because will to me is a strong word.
It says we're going to do that. May just
opens it up to the fact that it's just a possibility. And I don't know
how that would sit with you either, so I'm going to throw that out there
and see how the council feels about it. And then I'll ask— I think the
main thing is, is that's something you want to negotiate. For me,
it's— that's not a tool. The other things, I think we can talk about any
of those other things, but water's not on the table for me. And I think
if we want to talk about that under different circumstances as
part of a master development agreement or an amendment to a master development agreement,
that's different. But I think putting that out there and saying that that's
a negotiating tool that we're willing to do is the wrong message.
So for me, it would be simply just removing EI
from that. I'm fine with the rest. How do you feel about that, Mr.
Mackey? To me, it's all a negotiation,
right? That's the whole point of this memorandum, is trying
to find a way that we can come to a win-win solution.
And so if that's not on the table, then there will be something
else that has to be negotiated.
So, so what I mean, you say, Councilmember Wood, is if,
if I is removed, that then you're going to be okay with that? There's a
lot of other things in there that they get a benefit
out of that we don't even need to have a discussion about water. I mean,
density transfer, increased density, I mean, all those things, those reduced setbacks,
those are big asks already. So then what I'm going to suggest
is that we change the city not will but may consider providing benefits
to the developer, which may include removing I and
just going forward with II from there forward,
right? Is the council going to be okay with that?
That seems fair. Yeah, I mean, there's a lot to— You okay with that,
Brad? We'll work through it. We're going to have some negotiation.
This is not done. Yeah, this is— again, this is a— it's
a template to say we're— a template of, of something
to start a negotiation to work on, on a solution
that benefits everyone. Okay, then, Mayor,
if we're ready, can we, can we move to a motion I'm happy
to entertain a motion. All right, let me get there. You want me to make
it since I made the last one? Go ahead, go ahead. I mean, I'm happy
to do it. Mayor, I move that the City Council approve
Item 14B, a resolution of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, approving a memorandum
of agreement with Ivory Homes with an adjustment to
Section E. The language will say city's consideration the
city may consider providing benefits to the developer,
which may include then omitting I and
continuing with II. Second. All right,
we have a motion by Councilmember Wood and a second by Councilmember Wright, and we'll
start the vote with Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes.
Okay, that concludes our consent agenda, and we'll move on to our scheduled item.
Thank you, Brad.
Um, our next item is item 15A. It's an ordinance, uh,
uh, and a public— this is a public hearing. An ordinance of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code Chapter 17.10.030
Definitions and 17.25.040
Residential Development Standards. And this will be presented by our
long-range planner, Elizabeth Fuchs.
Good evening, Mayor and Council. So first, I wanted
to start out with explaining the genesis of this item.
So a few months ago, we approved the WUI map,
so the Wildland Urban Interface map. And in preparation for that,
Brandon and I met with the fire officials and discussed different aspects
of that map. And during that conversation, I asked
if there was anything we could do as a city to improve
our ability to survive and fight
against wildfires. And so this was recommended by the fire officials.
As something that we could do, and so I'm bringing it to the council
in that light of explaining this is an option, something we could consider as
a city to implement. But it's certainly not required by
the state code or city code or anywhere. This is just an
option for us. And so after that suggestion, I started
looking into where else has this been done? Who else?
Which other jurisdictions are doing this? And most of the places that
I found. Found were counties outside of Utah. So this
isn't something that is widely implemented even within the state.
This would be something a little different for us to do.
And so we don't have— like, it wouldn't be a copy-paste of
something done somewhere else. We would want to adapt those standards for
what would make sense for our city if we chose to go in this direction.
I thought it was still worth bringing to the council to
consider this, even though it, it isn't really being done elsewhere.
Because unlike other cities, a lot of other cities, we're surrounded
mostly by wildlands, and we don't intend to fully build out.
We want to protect washes and natural open space.
And also, we have a lot of large lots, and a lot of those don't
have fully improved yards. And these are all
great things for our community, but it does also increase the risk of wildfire
spreading through our city. So as I
looked at kind of the pros and cons of this, there are some challenges.
There's difficulty in defining exactly where we want this to go,
and we can— the— I call it wooey boundary lots, and we can
dive into that here in a minute. Now, it could increase the housing
costs because if we were to put in this greater setback, it would
most likely need to have a larger lot in order to
accommodate those. So these boundary lots would then be required for safety
to be larger. And it could limit and impede
the placement of accessory structures if we were to choose to include those in the
standards. But the benefits of this, kind of the reasons we might wanna consider
this, is it helps protect residents and their properties.
So the WUI code suggests a 30-foot setback.
Because usually a 30 or greater setback on
the property of well-maintained space cleared of vegetation
drastically improves the chances of that structure surviving
when a wildfire comes through. And this would create a
fire perimeter around the city.
They talk about defensible space when they're— when it
comes to fire prevention with wildfires. And so
I think of it kind of cities used to have walls around them
because the best way to prevent to protect your city is to prevent
a threat from ever getting inside. So these properties would kind of be the first
line of defense for that wildfire. So not only would it protect
their properties, but if we can stop it there, it's not going to get
inside the city anywhere else.
And HB 48. From last year,
properties in that WUI area are now going to be charged fees by
the state, and they can reduce those fees if they
do certain things to make their, their,
um, properties more resilient against wildfires.
And one of that is to create a 30-foot defensible space.
But the state code says it's 30 feet or to the property line.
As, as you raised, okay, if you don't own all 30 feet,
you can't really clear it. And this takes into
account, let's say that on the other side is a wash or a hillside.
We don't want them, you know, you clear out the vegetation,
that's going to help with fires, but that's going to cause some other issues if
we start clearing out all the vegetation off the hillsides
and out of the washes. So this would make sure that they have 30
feet of defensible space on their property that
it's— they don't have to worry about another
property. And hopefully it would help. I know
we've talked about people haven't been able to qualify for
fire insurance. And this won't guarantee it.
But if we're a unique city saying, hey, we're doing something to protect
against wildfires, hopefully we could help our residents
be able to qualify for it, for insurance.
So I wanted to pause here before we take a
look at any of the code and just do a
pulse check and see, is this something that the council is
interested in considering?
Uh, so my, my home insurance was canceled because of the
way that the fire department ranks where
I live. That all gets aggregated into data that goes back
to the insurance company. Mm-hmm. And they just sent me a letter and said,
you need a new insurance carrier by next month. And so I had to
shop. I've got some weird company I've never heard of. They're insuring my house now.
And I'm just curious if we add maybe a more restrictive
or more uniform code like this, and I don't see our fire
people here, could that improve that score
across our city? I think Brett is online. That's what I would want to
know. Is he online? He said he was going to try to be there.
Yeah. Yeah, I'm online. Can you restate
that question? It kind of got cut off. It wasn't a great question.
Let me try to rephrase it. If we adopt more
restrictive policies around our WUI,
will it help the fire scoring to better
inform the insurance companies so we have less people losing their home
insurance policies is my question.
I— that's a hard question. And I don't have— I
don't think we have a good answer and I don't think we will have a
good answer due to the fact that the insurance companies,
even when municipalities in certain jurisdictions have
established higher thresholds, It really hasn't.
Insurance companies have still come in and canceled insurances due
to the risk and the payouts that have been associated with those risks.
So I think it would be a hard— I think it
would be difficult for us to anticipate that at best.
I would—
And Dan DeVogue, who's the fire marshal over Our
area. And historically,
when you look at fires in general and the history of
major disasters and fires that have ripped through neighborhoods
and jurisdictions, you will
always notice that there are certain houses that are spared. And there's
been a lot of study that goes into why those have been spared.
And it almost always comes back to defensible space or God's grace.
Right. Those are kind of the two things that get pointed to.
So the biggest thing is defensible space. The 30, 30 to 50
feet is, is what has been preached for years. And it is
something that we feel strongly about that will
save homes ultimately,
especially if we have a wind-driven, wind-aligned event.
in high bluey areas. And so that's kind of the
background behind it. So sorry to go on a diatribe
outside of the question that was asked. The answer to that question, I don't think
that we have a good answer. I don't think we will have a good answer.
And, you know, if we have high insurance payouts, it very
well may not matter what we do with
the municipality because insurance companies can kind of— I think that's a great point.
Now, I know legislatively they're taking a look at different things
to be able to manage it, but that's kind of what I
would anticipate. And Marcus may be able to weigh in a little
bit more in depth on that one.
I mean, he's not wrong. Insurance companies are going to contract and do business
with whom they want to. And there's no law in the
state of Utah that will requires them to insure a specific home.
Yeah, my understanding was that there are scores.
Right. I mean, it wouldn't hurt.
It's a question of whether it would help. It's not going to hurt.
The ISO rating is a component of the fire response times,
a component of the water system and the water availability into a given neighborhood.
And all of these type of things is a comprehensive look. We actually have a
pretty high ISO rating right now, which is pretty good.
But different areas of town, and depending on how close you are to a hydrant
and all that kind of thing, can affect insurance
companies. Nothing can compel them to actually insure,
but I think you're seeing nationwide this happening all over
the place. For sure. When I was in Iowa,
companies were just pulling out of the state just for no other reason than tornadoes
and ripping shingles off roofs and whatnot.
So insurance companies are becoming more and more risk-averse.
So I guess the question then is the real benefit that
we can hope to help them with is what they're being fined,
and then obviously the 30-foot barriers,
trying to prevent that from taking over the city. My concern
is going to obviously be their right to use their property.
I mean, some people, that's their entire backyard.
So I mean, I think that people are going to have some of those
concerns. I stated before, I feel like this,
this bill didn't go far enough. It's penalizing those that
bought a house that they had nothing to do with how big the backyard was,
and the adjacent owners don't have any responsibility to do
a fire line that goes up against those properties.
I would really like the state to have a more broad approach
and say, we don't know when those are going to be developed,
and so there should be 30 feet of fire line that's cut,
a road at the very minimum that protects the houses from the
structure from going through your property, which it's absolutely going to go through because that's
where the weeds are and the sagebrush and so forth. But yeah,
I mean, I, in principle, I think it's a good idea.
Uh, I'm not enthusiastic about taking people's sheds,
barns, and that kind of thing down and saying you can't have those.
Um, I'd love to see other options that they can do
to make them fire resistant as part of that plan if possible,
but that'd be my only 2 cents
on that. Um, just, just, uh,
I'll respond to him and then we'll go to, um, Council Member
Clark. So we do have it in there. Well, first,
it would only apply to the O's that require a building permit.
So that means they're over 200 square feet or they have
electrical or plumbing to them. But we also do have the option
that if they were to— that they could get an approval if they were
to have them be— have fire safety taken into
account. So like if they did a metal shed or other fire-resistant material,
then they would— we would allow exceptions for that reason.
Because we don't— we wanted this to be about fire protection,
not doing that. And the Planning Commission did suggest
adding accessory dwellings in there. Of course, if the council
doesn't want accessory dwellings, we could Accessory building, sorry.
We could take that out. I think for me,
there's been so many times where a project's come before us— Oh. That was
Amber? Was that Brett? Go ahead.
Maybe not. Yeah, sorry. It's hard to talk.
No, can you hear me? Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, sorry, Council Member Clark, I didn't mean to cut you off. Um, one of
the other things to keep in mind too is this is, this is directly related
to the, the WUI high-risk areas and new builds within those
areas. Uh, and so it's not specifically,
um, going to take hold, you know, in throughout
the city or in all properties. It's primarily going
to be in those high- high-risk areas that have already been identified by the state
that are still going to get taxed and, and have some fee assessed.
This will help, uh, to protect those areas
as they do builds. So, uh, Councilmember Clark, I apologize to cut
you off. No worries. It's hard when we have delays and different
things. So what I started to say was there's been so many projects that have
come before me, and I think all of us where we, we can look at
it and we can say that's not going to work because
someone's trying to get the most lots out of it humanly possible,
and we know that the wash is going to impede something,
the slope is going to impede something, and now we have
the WUI adjacent setback that would— and the fire risk,
I guess, is the best way to say that. And we can only say no
or force something with very specific things: health,
safety, and welfare. And this is very specifically for
safety. This is a tool that allows us as
a land use decision body that to look at a
project and say, we have this setback now,
and for safety reasons, we're going to require that these lots are bigger
or there's bigger setbacks. And I get that that will increase
some lots' prices, but the reality of it is, is not every
lot in every city is made for every financial
situation. And the people who could have a lot like this were—
are going to be in a better position to have that setback and to leave
that space and have that defensible space. For that
reason, I'm inclined to approve this because it's another really
good tool for us as decision makers to make sure that our neighborhoods,
especially the ones adjacent to WUI, are safer.
Just a follow-up question. Um,
maybe this is obvious to everybody else but not to me. So the
WUI can exist within our city boundaries. It's not just the outward boundaries that we're
talking about. That being the case, they can fall out
of that as well as the next subdivision is built. So the
question that I'm thinking of in my mind is, what are we doing to notify
the people who are buying the house that can't do anything with their backyard?
Because I can promise you the developer's not going to tell them that. Yeah.
I think if we're going to implement something like that, there needs to be some
responsibility placed on those who are building the property to let
that be known as part of the process, that you are in a WUI
area 30 feet of your backyard.
is not buildable for any accessory, anything back
there. Because look, there's a lot of things we don't have to take responsibility
for— people's views and the sky above and any of those kind of things.
But if you're going to put a restriction like that on the property, they need
to be notified in a way that's meaningful. So this would only impact new properties,
so new builds. So it would be something that we, we would be
looking at as we're approving Plots and and
and developments. That's what I'm looking at. I'm looking at the ones that are coming
into it, and they're saying, "Great, I got this brand new house I built." What
I didn't know is that I can't put anything in my backyard. I think it's
important that that if they're in the WUI that we need to let them know
that they exist in that zone. That needs to be something that is required of
the builder to let them know. Also, to let them know that as the
next development is done, they will fall out of that. But for whatever
that period of time is, like, we need to help them to be aware of
what they're saying yes to. So if we're putting the restriction there,
I will— let's dive into the code because I,
I realize this might need some more work, and I'm fine if we table it
and come back. I wanted to start— have a starting
point because I figure it's easier to start with something than to
start with nothing. And my hope is to try to impact as few
properties as possible and not have
the properties who are falling out of it for it to apply to them.
So that did make some of the trying to define things a little
tricky. But when I talked about that wall,
if you think about it that way, it would only be
the properties on the wall. So if you have a property and
right now it's the last property between you and a hillside,
but there's developable and buildable land behind you,
that means it's going to be large enough and level enough to put in
housing or a business. Then that's a defensible
space for the city, so it wouldn't apply to you. This only
applies to people if you are up against a wash or a hillside,
the very perimeter of the city Where we don't
have— there's behind you, that land is never slated to be
developed. This— the people it might— that it could impact is
if we annexed in later. So those people may end up with a bigger setback
and then development goes in behind them, but it's not meant,
oh, you're Phase 1, so you have to have a 30-foot setback,
and then Phase 2 goes in and the edge of that has to have a
30-foot setback. But it could be a Phase 2 It could be,
but again, if that land's large enough and level
enough, we would be able to defend the city from
there. So that was my thought process. We can change that,
but trying to— again, we— this is for safety.
If we can accomplish safety without impeding their
land rights, then we want to do that. I think
one of the questions that I have about this, Beth, is— and I'm thinking specifically
of Circle 5. Circle 5 is in the WUI. I think it's identified as
a WUI-5 area, and we know that there are entitlements in that area. And I'm
just thinking, how's the developer who already has some existing entitlements in there,
how's he going to make this function in an
existing area? So I mean, I kind of— I'm hearing
all of this, and what I'm hearing is a desire
to think about how could we create
safer areas in the city, and I think that's an admirable desire.
But I also think we need to look at what's the real-world impact to
existing entitlements and
to those future entitlements. And if it's just gonna pertain to future and
we're only looking for the boundary, where's that boundary at? Yeah. You know,
because it's this boundary today and it's that boundary tomorrow and it's this
boundary in Eagle Mountain 6 months from now, right?
I mean, it's just, it's always moving. And so
I'm really wrestling with this. I get the safety aspect
of it as somebody who deals with this on his own property.
And I'm really wrestling with creating additional
government red tape that individuals have to deal with that they
wouldn't otherwise have to deal with because they live in Eagle Mountain City. So I'm,
I'm, I'm kind of on the fence with this one. If I looked
at it today, I'd probably just be a no, but I think if we
can engage in it and perhaps find a better way to get to a yes,
and we can understand Embritt's position and how we
can incorporate that a little, a little better, but I'm not prepared to say yes
to this. this today. I'll just put it that way. So I,
I mean, I know there's a public hearing, Mayor, but I think we should do
what we can to get into that portion of it. And I don't see
this moving forward today. Well, I, I was going to ask that too,
depending on kind of the direction for the council. I don't know how much of
the presentation— I know you said you went this far, um, how much would apply
to the public hearing as beneficial to the public,
for the simple reason that if it's going to change a lot And this is
going to be unpopular. I hate noticing it again, but if it's not the
same thing, I also find that unfair to
the public. So I'm willing to have a public hearing on this as it
stands today, but if it's going to come back,
can— we'd have to re-notice it, even if we pass it.
I mean, it depends on the, you know, how major the changes
that you're contemplating are. I mean, if you're talking about pretty significant changes.
I mean— So, Marcus, here's the question though.
In the past, we've left the public hearing open.
Do you have to re-notice it if that's— I mean, so, I mean, if you're
tabling it to a specific date, then I would say no,
because that's— people who wanted to comment on this code were on notice that
we were having a public hearing today, and they would be on
notice of the new date if the motion to table.
And so that, that has, you know, serves the function of the public notice.
If we don't know when we're coming back, we're going to have to re-notice it
either way. Okay. And the other thing I was thinking is we
could have the public hearing, and if there's no one here that came to comment
on this anyway, then I'd be a little bit more comfortable. But again, if there's
significant changes. So I was just curious about that.
If— and I've kind of heard a little bit of both, that maybe it's okay,
maybe it's not. So I'm looking for direction from the council.
Do you want me to continue with the public hearing?
Well, how much longer do you have in your presentation? Like, were you toward the
end, or is there like a lot more? Is there more salient details the public
would want to hear right now? I could give just a really quick summary that
might— for the public. So basically,
The code, other than defining where this— the first part defines
which properties it would apply to, and basically it would have
a 30-foot setback for primary structures,
and then there is that they could apply
for an exception. And mainly this will impact R-1
and smaller for rear setbacks. It's really only
a corner property it might do a side setback.
They'd have to have more property on the side of their lots.
But larger lots have 35 rear setbacks
anyway. And then the accessory dwellings—
accessory dwellings— accessory buildings,
it would also have a 30-foot setback for those. Again,
you could, if your shed's smaller than 200 feet,
it wouldn't impact you. So it's only if it's above 200 or
has like electrical and plumbing. So, and, and then the
Planning Commission, they recommended having those accessory
buildings in it as well, accessory structures. And Council
Member Wright, just curious, some of our other exceptions, if you will,
are actually decisions made at Planning Commission.
But if the exceptions are built into this for places like Circle 5 that
says, hey, this is our suggested rules,
if you will, but just like a mitigation plan for
other codes, if they could come with some kind of plan
or exception, request for exception, that it's easily mitigated,
does that make this better?
I mean, I see it as very difficult. I'm just going to put it this
way. If I move into a piece of property and I buy it and I'm
subject to this and I establish all of that and at
some point the adjacent property develops,
now suddenly I'm being restricted to use my property just as anybody
else in the city can. I can't build a shed within 5 feet
of the property line because I've got— I have to meet the 30-foot or I've
been held to that standard and then it changes. I just think there's a lot
of ambiguity in it. And I just
see it as a code enforcement nightmare. How do you know?
And when you're bringing an application, well, does it still apply
or is it outdated? When did we update it last? And I just hear all
of these arguments from the individual property owners when they're
trying to build an accessory dwelling. I'll just add to that.
In my— I'm just thinking of my neighbors. We live by
Airport Road. 80-foot setback for an
airport easement. I've never had a plane crash. But it
exists because of the FAA, and it severely restricts my ability.
You have to push all of your sheds, all of the outbuildings
toward your house when I'd rather have them back, you know, up against
my fence. I have neighbors who have horses, they have,
you know, barns and places that they store their hay, those are going to
Like, like a, you know, that'll create a fire.
So I, I find it would be hard to, to manage that and,
and enforce it. I think I'm probably a no at this
point. Like, we should comply with the state, but I think
it's going to be difficult to do it on new builds going forward and large
lots and creates issues for the developer as well. If,
if this is the direction I'm hearing, it's still a split. I think I want
to move forward with the public hearing and we'll just— and we'll see where it
lands. So with that, I think we've got some pretty
good information and some good commentary.
I do want to open the public hearing at this time. It is 8:26 and
ask if anyone has— none.
Is there anyone here that would like to speak on this item that did not
have an opportunity? Yes. Seeing no one,
I'll close the public hearing.
And if we have to do it again, we'll have to re-notice. It's 8:26.
We'll close the public hearing and bring it back to the council for further
discussion. I'll throw out another idea, Mayor. I'm just sitting here thinking about
this because I— look, I think the safety aspect of this can't be,
um, just dismissed, right? It does matter.
And— but I'm wondering if this is the right approach. That's really what I'm sitting
I'm wondering if we shouldn't put together something that
is like a detailed recommendation for new builds that are in adjacency
to the WUI and allow those private homeowners to make
those decisions. That we're giving them some recommendations that will help keep
them safe and create that defensible state. I don't know
what the answer is, but I think we have to develop this a little bit
further before I'm going to be ready to say yes. What I hear you saying
is more of a carrot approach instead of a stick,
and I think that that's always a better— that's good governance,
is to help educate, provide resources,
knowledge, all of those things. So like, I, I actually,
when Councilmember Hughes was speaking, I started thinking about the fact that maybe
what we need to be doing is more education in these areas.
But I think that The education approach or what
you just said is going to be just as difficult to get
the information out to new homeowners who are moving in. So I feel like while
this is a valiant effort, there's no real solution for
us to solve the problem that this code's trying to solve.
I think there needs to be shared responsibility too, and I don't know if that's
something that we can, that we can require. I mean, I believe
that there needs to be some responsibility of the homeowners, the developers, a certain space,
but I don't think that negates the responsibility of the landowners. If we're requiring
them to retain their water on their property regardless if
it's done or not, why would we not require them to put a defensible
fire line on their property so that they're not the cause of the fire spreading
and ruining all the homes adjacent to it? I mean, I just— if we're going
to go down that road, it needs to be a shared responsibility. Responsibility, in my
opinion. Then you have 15 on one side and 15 on the other side.
It also gives access to the fire department on
the property that isn't developed to be able to fight the fire. You essentially
have a fire road. Or if you do build something within that 30-foot
space, have defined materials that it could be built out of,
and we'd probably need to define that: metal roofs, metal exterior.
It's concrete, tilt-up. Concrete, everything.
If there's work to be done on it, it's probably
not this one, is what it sounds like. I'll make a motion if you're okay
with that. I'm okay with that if you give specific direction. I know Bess put
a lot of time into this, so if you— if we're just not interested,
or if you want to— Do you— so let me ask this of the council.
Do you feel like the wording in this is something we want to keep,
or do we want to start over? That'll determine how I make my motion.
Well, it sounds like we had a good idea developing here with, okay, so if
you want an accessory, like some kind of structure within that 30 feet, it has
to be made out of certain materials. That makes sense. Does that solve all the
problems? Well, right now it's restricted,
so does that lift the restriction if it meets the requirement? For the accessory
dwelling, that was an— recommendation by the Planning Commission. So that
would be in above what they originally brought. Do we think the 30
feet needs to exist all on one property? Does it need to be shared?
One of the things that I keep going back to though is even if we
do put those things, answering your questions, who's going to enforce it?
Is it going to be enforced at site plan stage? What if they don't
have a shed at that point? And if they don't have to have a
building permit because it doesn't exceed 200 square feet and it doesn't
have a utility going to it, then there's
no enforcement for that. Like, it feels like we've
kind of opened Pandora's box with this, and that's where I'm kind of getting held
up right now. That's where I'm at. So it sounds like we probably just deny
this then. Okay, uh, Mayor, I move that
the City Council deny 15A, an ordinance Eagle Mountain
City, Utah, amending Eagle Mountain Municipal Code Chapter 17.10.030,
Definitions, and 17.25.040,
Residential Development Standards.
Second. I have a motion by Council Member Wood and a second by Council Member
Wright, and we will start the vote with Council Member Hughes.
Yes. Council Member Clark. Yes. Council Member
Wright? Yes. Yes. Yes. All right,
that passes 5-0 to deny that.
I still think we should work on this. So, so that, that's where I was—
With that said, I still think we should be having some discussion about how do
we, how do we create some defensible space. Beth? Yeah, I'm not offended by this
at all because I was struggling with it, how, how to work it out.
But the same thing, it's a good concept,
but I didn't think this was going to pass tonight as written because I recognized
it had some issues. So maybe we'll have some more conversations, more thoughts,
and see if we can come up with something that'll work better. I think it
probably gives us the, the direction of maybe we need to start
looking at what accessory structures
should be. Perhaps we shouldn't be saying yes to ones that are made of wood,
especially those that are being built that Maybe it needs to be that we're doing
metal requirements because we are literally
in an area where wildfires are a problem. That's some of the things
that we probably need to start looking at, just like we're looking at conservation efforts
for land to use less water and things like that. I think this is part
of that overall discussion of perhaps some of those standards need to change,
especially in those areas where it's been identified.
that's the beginning of the conversation. And I do think education's part of
it, because if it were my home, I might not know that,
but I would want to know things I could do to protect my home.
I think we need to remember this is part of the Circle 5. Like,
when it comes back at some point for approval, we need to remember adding
some language in that, that agreement pertaining to fire
standards. Okay, I know Brandon's been trying to— Circle 5 is coming I'll be
coming back to you at the next meeting. And, uh, and,
uh, the other thing I was going to say, um,
now that I've told you that, um, the state's adopting the
2024 WUI code. And so that becomes effective,
I think, July 1st, somewhere around that time frame.
And so it'll be good to dive into that more and understand it better because
there are defensible space requirements in there. And so after becoming
more familiar with that, we might have some better recommendations for you.
So, Brandon, and I was just— I mean, I asked the mayor if I could
say one more thing, and, and I'll say one more thing and then I'll be
done. I just think that we may need to consider some additional development
standards on those areas that are adjacent to a WUI. And what that does is
it creates some of that buffering and requires some larger lots to buffer against
that to help create that transition. And I recognize that that's temporary and that it's
going to move, but I also think it accomplishes some of the things that we've
been trying to do, is to encourage some
larger lot development, in particular in the foothills and some of those areas
that are adjacent to these WUI standardized areas. So I think there's
some room to do some really unique and creative things with this.
So that was a great suggestion, and I just want to
make sure we capture that. 'Cause I know that Beth works hard and sometimes
these things just stall out. And I was
going to say in 30 seconds or less, but I know what that really means
is add 2 zeros for everybody here. So, you know, like,
what exactly do you want Beth to, like, focus on? Building materials,
larger lots, I hear. I just want to make sure that she's not just
spinning wheels to get— you know, what should we be doing to— Yeah.
Yeah, I know Craig's talked about a lot of building materials, alternative foam,
and— Thank you for your time on this. I think it's really important.
And what I— just having the conversation
is key. I'm thinking about the building materials,
enclosed hay barns, things like that, that if you're in that space,
especially if there's animal rights that we have— You want them enclosed or not
enclosed? Enclosed can be worse for combustion. Well,
yeah, I mean, whatever would be the safest
in that case. If it's hay, I mean, it depends on how it is when
it's put in there. Yeah, it just— if it's moldy, it's going to start and
create heat. Right. There's just no good answer. So it's materials.
Mayor would have some insights on hay barns, but I'm thinking of like 5
neighbors right now. If it hits my neighborhood, we're in trouble because they're all up
against the property line. Just quickly,
I think Brett's suggestion about the larger lots on
the outside, I think that's, that's a pretty easy thing
to, to require because that will enable them to have the 30 feet
and still have usable land. If we do that with quarter acres or
smaller, they have no land. So I think that's step one.
I think our fire department
help us with what materials are combustible, what are not, what are
just going to melt in place. Like, I think they can help us with the
standards for those things. And Dan DeVogue should know some of that stuff as well.
And then I think anything that's on the perimeter of the city is probably where
we begin with that defensible line. And perhaps that's not just areas
that are built that we require Require landowners to create that defensible
line around our city. Well, and I think if we're dealing with larger lots,
that 30 feet could either be a setback from
the property line or between the buildings.
Then they might lose the accessory structure. You know, it'd be their
choice, but then they would have more freedom with
their— To your question, Brett, the way you enforce it is you contact the person
who owns that parcel and them that they have a requirement to clear brush so
it doesn't spread a fire. And that, it's done in other cities. That's not
new. I lived in— by the way, I lived in San Diego County when the
fires were there, and the people who were on the periphery had a requirement
to clear brush. So it's not a new, new thing. I was there when the
whole place was on fire, and I had 4 inches of soot on my house.
So yeah, it can be done, and it's something that we can enforce. force.
We just need to. And some of that is going to be— the state
is doing that. They're having people come out and inspect their
properties, and if they do certain things, their fees are going to go down.
So the state will be informing them as well that they are in
a high-risk area.
Any more
comments? I'm just wondering, is there
a way— do we need to be looking at areas that aren't necessarily necessarily up
against WUI, because people have said, what happens when something else
gets developed and that WUI goes away?
But I look at areas like Kiowa Valley, in the
middle of Fremont Springs, Porter's Crossing. I mean, we literally have a
mountain in the middle of our neighborhood that's covered in fire. Yeah.
You know, everything. And we've had fires there,
and we've had to be evacuated a couple So like,
even though those homes exist, and technically there may not
be a WUI just on the other side of them, there's still that danger there.
So regardless of where we land with code, I think the education piece
definitely needs to roll forward. And then I want to say one other thing.
I think so many times people think that city council comes
to meetings and it's a foregone conclusion. We've all decided
what we want to do and that's it. But the tonight was a really great
example of a staff member and council
throwing their different thoughts out there and coming to a conclusion that
we could all get behind. And I think that's the beauty
of having a body of people that make decisions for our
city. We all help make the decisions better. So I'm just going to say that.
I don't even think we agree on much other than the minutes.
But anyway, I think that's a pretty good direction.
I want to cut this off. So are you— you
know where we're going? Yeah, that's good. Thanks. Kind of.
Yeah. Glad you do, because I don't. Thank you.
We'll hope to see that. And we want to keep our residents safe, but sometimes
that infringes on our own freedoms, right? So Yeah,
all right, one more item. It's Item 16A,
Ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, approving the Flagship Homes Development
Agreement. And Marcus has some information.
Yeah, this is an identical agreement to the one we did with Meritage Homes.
This is also in Harmony Development, and so it's an
attempt to treat Flagship the same that we treated— in
the same way that we treated Meritage.
So essentially let them do a bond and come back and do it at the
end? Yeah, they would bond and have a, you know,
9-month sort of deadline to start.
I have a thought sort of related to this.
Have we considered the possibility of buying the
forms for these types of fences? And working something
out with contractors so we have some uniformity with these going down the
road? We can do what exactly? The forms for the walls,
these concrete walls. Have we considered that? Is that something— When you said have we
considered, we have. We as the city. Is that something that anybody's talked
about at the staff level of owning the forms to
be able to create these and maybe reducing some of the cost associated
with that? I don't believe that's something that's been considered.
Might be something to talk about and see if it is— if it's not financially
feasible, I mean, I'm a no. But if it's something that would reduce the cost
and get the uniformity and make it easy to replace them, might be something
to consider. I think, Rich, to that, I mean, I know I've worked in this
industry for a long time, and it goes along with excavating gravel pits. Some of
those pits and concrete places will hold the forms, pour them,
and just deliver you the walls if you have a specific pattern, for instance.
Maybe it has their logo on it. What I'm recommending
is that maybe we ask John in our legislative
to look into some of the costs and
if we want to add that to the list, because I think it's something that
we could consider and then have that brought back. It would be fairly simple.
So unless— if there's no other comments, I know Craig's itching to make a motion.
Mayor, I move that the City Council approve Agenda Item 16A,
an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City Utah approving the Flagship Homes Development Agreement.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting, a second by Councilmember
Wood, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright.
Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Okay,
good work. We got through that. With that, I think John
is still here. Um, great opportunity
to bring that up. Okay, yeah, if you don't mind. Basically, John,
if you could maybe do some research into
whether it would be cost-effective, first of all, for us to acquire the
mold, or the forms, I mean, for these
concrete panels. Jared and I have talked a little bit about this.
Essentially, you have posts that have channels in them.
You pour these concrete slabs. They slide
down in the channels. If we had something like that,
perhaps this becomes less onerous and less costly for
us to have this standard along all of our arterial. They're easy to replace
if they're damaged, and maybe that becomes a partnership
that we can work out with, to Jared's point, with the
pits that are— have their own cement factories
there that they can pour some of these things. I know they do blocks and
things things like that there. But it would be maybe something that could offset
some of the cost. I know that's usually the biggest problem is the, the cost
of doing that that a lot of developers have. That helps us to be able
to accomplish the safety aspect that we're looking for, create some
uniform, uh, looks on our arterial roads.
And it's something that, uh, we don't have to worry about changing of
companies going out of business or whatever. We can maintain
that uniformity. That's just an idea that I've been thinking about. 6 feet? Yeah,
they're 6 feet. Yeah, the size of the wall. So those panels are usually 6
feet tall by— do you remember, they're 8 feet long? I didn't even give you
a chance to speak. 8 or 10.
Your item was 2— 10. They're 10-footers. Okay, I couldn't remember.
So 6 by 10 panels. And just because
usually that's done by motion, but I want to make sure that council is Is
there anybody that thinks that that might be a benefit? I just feel like,
why not? There's no reason to not look into it. Yeah. Okay.
Well, can I make the motion to that effect? Yeah. I move that we add
that to the legislative priorities list and have John do some research about the
cost associated with that and see if it's financially beneficial to
do so. Second. Okay. We have a motion and a second by Councilmember Huebsch.
And I just want to ask before we go to vote, are you clear on
the Okay, just making sure. Any questions on
the motion? Councilman Wright? Yes. Councilman Whiting? Yes. Councilman Wood?
Yes. Councilmember Hewish? Yes. Councilmember Clark? Yes. Okay, are there
any other legislative— well, while we're on this note, I want to— is there anything
else that we need to talk about for the list? Yeah. Okay.
You and I talked a little bit about this, Mayor, and it's— and I know
that John's at least been looking into it on the surface, but I
think a I think as a council, we need to discuss water
policy with regards to the paper rights that we're
accepting and the prioritization dates. Didn't we
already set a policy, or are you asking to set a policy? I'm asking for
us to work with John and for the council to really
come together and gain some further understanding from John
and see if we can't come up with crafting some guardrails that we
want to put in place so that we're not accepting really new water rights that
are at a higher probability of being removed. I thought we already
had that in our policy. That's not in there now? No. Okay, that's good.
And so I just think that there's wisdom in adopting something
like that, and there's a lot of moving parts to this.
And so I'm hoping John will educate us and that we as a body can
then kind of say, okay, Knowing all this information, what do we want to
do? Because the prioritization date's important,
understanding that— I think— so can I add a little bit
to that? We've been to some meetings and I know what we're looking for.
And I know John could help us with— and I'll say this, John— with
maybe drafting some of that code. But I don't know if that wouldn't need a
little help. He could follow up or track it. But I think we're asking John,
shoot, to maybe look at. Well, and I'm
going to say, having had the conversations I have with— oh, Ben looks like
he needs to get in here. I'll be quiet for a minute. I was just
going to say, John Schutz, in coordination with Hanson Allen Luce, with our engineers,
because I think there's a combination of strategies
that engineering and legal both bring to help
you make a better decision. And then maybe have John— Educate us.
marry those together or whatever to our policy.
Yeah, and you can kind of track it, but I think we're going to need
that expertise, no? So, so with, with that said,
um, if we're going to do it, I, I just kind of feel like we
need to, we need to take an hour with those parties in the room and
just have a conversation where we can become better educated.
And, and I don't know when or how that happens. I don't know. Well,
we've sort of Yeah, we've been trying to— we don't have a specific date,
but Evan, I think, tracks those offsites, or Ben can.
But that definitely needs to be one of our agenda items,
to create a policy around water right allocations.
And specifically, I think
we need to create a policy around the paper water rights that we accept,
and with the specificity about their I
don't know what the right terminology is, John. It's their priority date.
The prioritization date that those water rights are associated with.
I think that's really important, because there's some
strategies that I think we need to employ there. Right, 'cause if we just look
at priority dates, that's just like taking a hammer when we need a scalpel.
Because sometimes when you get a change application, the priority date moves to the change
application, which is okay, because the parent right, still has the older one.
Um, but that only applies to a water right in '54 block. If it came
from '55 or '59, then the change application is the new date.
That's why we want you on point, John, because you understand this. That's— yeah.
So, right, there's— we can definitely say these are some good
water rights, and there's some bad water rights, and there's some that are going to
be in this gray area where we need council direction to— if you want
to accept them. But yeah, it's a lot of moving parts to Will you just
let me make a motion then? I move that the City Council put on the
prioritization list that we direct
you and staff to work with us to create water policy associated
with prioritization dates of the paper water rights.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Wright
and a second by Councilmember Wood, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Weiting.
Yes. Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Huish? Yes. Councilmember Clark?
Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes. Okay,
any other additions to the priority? I have
a follow-up from 2 weeks ago. We had a member, a citizen of Meadow
Ranch, come and let us know that the equine overlay zone inadvertently
missed, you know, the extra development that had happened.
Is that on anybody's plate right now, or is that just Because I think we've
got to move that ball forward. I'm not a member,
actually, so do you remember? I don't. I remember the conversation.
I remember him coming for open comment.
He did. We will follow up on that. Do we need
to put that on the list? No, staff will take the direction
to follow up on that comment and report back to the council. Okay. I think
we'd want to get that— we want to get that extended. To where it should
be. Yeah, and we shouldn't hopefully wait too long. I know we got a lot
the city's working on, but— I just have a clarification
on— I'm not sure where this landed on the priorities list. I think I took,
took it back to do some homework, and this is on making— having
the ability to make payments to the city in Bitcoin, not utilities,
but application fees, things like that. Is that on
the— It's on the priority list. Yeah, it's on the priority list. I've started.
Poking my nose in, but right now we're— Have you really? Okay. All right.
With Finn getting ready to retire, we're working on some water issues we want to
get wrapped up. I'm stoked. We would be the 4th city in America,
the 1st in Utah. It would be way cool. Utah actually
accepts Bitcoin for paying your taxes,
FYI. Yeah, it is possible.
We just have to find out if our vendor can actually do it. Yeah,
I think most of the cities that I looked at, they're doing— they have a
connection through PayPal. Yeah, PayPal is the way to do it. The primary, yeah.
Okay, so if there aren't any other additions, I'll come back to the reports.
Brandon's actually gave a report on the stuff that he's covering tonight.
Well, just a couple questions.
So one,
we talked about the senior housing over Yes.
And then the overlay zone, or that idea you had, a presentation from Beth a
little while ago, is just a point of clarification.
There was some discussion about an overlay zone or
just a zone. Do you want us— do
you want us to produce both options,
an overlay and just a regular zone? Do you want one or
the other? direction from the council on how to do that. We were talking about
that today, and we weren't sure in our staff meeting how you— we
weren't clear on how to proceed with that. I'm wondering, does it need to be
a zone, or do we just add it as a right with standards in specific
zones? We could do that. That's a possibility.
I just don't want— I want the market to prescribe where these go as opposed
to us choosing where they go. So do you just allow them in certain
zones? I think you allow them in certain zones and let the developer make,
you know, sort of make applications to go that direction with
it. One thing I was thinking of
with an overlay is you guys get the opportunity to approve wherever
they go. So it gives you more say in where they go.
Mainly, you're talking about more like assisted livings in that? regard though, right?
Not senior housing, single family.
It's— I think that there's still options
on how that could go. I was thinking more of kind
of like your twin homes and things like that
instead of assisted living. And Beth, you can correct me if
I'm wrong. She's been more focused on this
than I have.
I don't know that has— maybe you can clarify. I don't know that we've talked
a lot about assisted living. I thought it was more like 55+ communities.
Well, our original understanding was an overlay. So we have
drafted the overlay and it kind of has all of those in there and different
options for them. Then I started working on his own, so we can
can bring both. We're going to Planning Commission with it at the next meeting,
so we want to make sure we present what the council wants.
And so there's pros and cons with both.
Putting it in— we could add it to existing zones, but where
we want different— to allow different housing
types, that was one of the things we were running into with a zone,
because you have both single-family And multifamily in the
same zone and figuring out how to add that to all the tables and everything
that we currently have in code. One of the things that I've
been thinking about is we want to incentivize them to do these. There are things
that we want. I don't know if a zone is
an incentive for them. I don't know if doing even just standards inside of a
zone— that's probably one of the things that we should contemplate.
How can we incentivize incentivize builders to do senior communities.
And I would make the argument, trying to help
multiple people in the last couple of years find senior housing,
they need to be gated, in my opinion, because they're not looking to
be existing in a regular neighborhood. Yes.
Because they could— the next person can come in and not have it be senior
housing if it's done in that regard. So then it stops meeting the purpose that
we did it in the first place. And you can disagree with that, but I
just think if we're going to do it, it needs to be specific. It should
probably be a gated community if we're talking about twin
homes, fourplexes. All need to be single level,
no stacked single houses,
any of those things. They all need to be patio-type homes.
But they don't want to take care of their property. I think that's a good
point. Why is that a requirement? I'm getting pretty close to 55. I can still
walk upstairs. I'm just throwing that out there. I mean, I've seen Brett go upstairs.
Yeah, I'm going to tell you, when people are going—
I can promise you, when you get to that point, Jared, the last thing you're
going to want to do with your back is going up and down the stairs.
And your wife's going to say, enough, I don't want to see you fall down
the stairs. But I'm going to tell you, I come from that community of
geriatric care. They're looking to prevent
slips and falls that generally end up in hip
breaking and things of that nature. So stairs is bad for
the senior community, and most of them are looking to get away from that because
they don't feel stable on the stairs. So I just— if we're
going to do it, what incentivizes them? They don't want to take care of
the property, so it needs to be something that's enclosed, so somebody else
is taking care of it. I think for For me, that's what I'm looking for
out of this. I don't care if it's an overlay zone, but it needs to
have some better guardrails, in my opinion. Okay,
because the overlay would be an easier mechanism to work in some
of those incentives because it's a whole chapter of code.
So it gives us more room to play with to add things into that.
Yeah, so I don't think it's a zone. I think perhaps it's an overlay.
And I mean, another strategy in my mind is to consider doing
it by development agreement only. I mean— Okay.
It's just what's the incentive, right? What's the incentive that gets
developers to pay attention to that? 'Cause frankly, I see
some of the amenities that these communities are going to have,
they're going to be higher and more expensive amenities.
And what incentivizes them to do that? That's my question.
How do you get them to want to do that? The market?
Yeah, but they'd be building them if the market demanded it, and we're not
seeing them being built right now. But if we give them enough density,
then— especially if their other option is X,
and we're going to give them more density with Y, then that will hopefully help.
I just— I'm— if it's only done by development
agreement, the challenge is, will the developer developers know that it's an option.
That's my only— we need to get a signal out to the development community.
We're looking for these types of product, like this kind of product type right now.
And so I just, I want to make sure they know it's an option.
Well, it would still be listed. We could still list it in code and just
have one of the things in the overlay that it would be done
through agreement. You've created development standards by which you're going to allow them.
I mean, I think that that's what you do, and you put those into the
types of uses. And then maybe it is a special use
in the very specific zones that you want to allow some of that to happen.
We want— one thing that we keep hearing about
is about education, and that's something we want to do too.
We really like Kyle and Soraya. Their team's really
good. And so we're working with them to find ways
to communicate more effectively, um, try to get
the word out about WUI and about the senior housing options that
might be available. And so we're, we're going to— we've had them come to
our staff meeting recently, and we're going to keep working with them to, to,
to get the word out on this, on, on these things. Ultimately, I guess
we're just looking to see what kind of tool you want, and then we'll— we,
we can kind of think through incentives and so forth
and bring something back to you. So I think we need to find a big
enough carrot. I think that's what it's going to come down to, because I'm going
to tell you, there's a market for it. They can't find any senior housing right
now. We just have to find a big enough incentive to get developed. And it
may be exactly what Craig's saying, that maybe it is density,
but density the Eagle Mountain way. Yeah.
Is there anything else on that one?
Did we get clear? Is an overlay zone right, or do
you want options?
I think overlay is good. Let's start with an overlay.
Okay. And we anticipate there'll be lots of conversation,
and it may take a few refinements before we get there, but we wanna
get it right. So thank you. The only other thing I was going to mention
is, so state
code, obviously, that we just went through the legislative session, and we've
got staff lined up to go through all these numerous codes to
see if we need to make any code changes. One in particular,
one or two that I'll particularly mention is we'll be working
on the political signage, and kind of
connected to that is we've talked, and I think it's on the priorities list,
is the seasonal signage. We're working on a temporary
use code that kind of goes along with that. So those 3 things
are kind of tied to each other. I just wanted to let you know that
we'll be working on that, on those 3
things, temporary uses, political signs, and seasonal signs.
So we'll— Thank you. we'll get all those squared up.
Okay, that's all the items from Brandon. Was there any others?
Okay, for the legislative priorities. You know what, I've been sitting here
kind of leaning back thinking about when we get done before 9, and there was
some wagers about getting done before 9,
that we have more time to discuss these. We spent a ton of time on
that, and I like that. because we still have to talk about
liaison reports, so we're not gonna make it. But I think that—
I'm just pointing out that we had a lot of time and we got a
lot done. So any liaison reports? Thanks, guys.
Well, we had mine today with the Community Services Board,
and now our Planning Commission is fully staffed,
so— Yeah, I probably— Riveting report. And I probably missed the vote on taking
the opportunity to thank, uh, it's probably short stint, but Mandy for her service.
They got called out of state and they're moving to the Midwest,
and so we appreciate her service on the Planning Commission. So that
was awesome. Um, I'm meeting with the library board tomorrow.
I met with the Chamber of Commerce last week. They got a great CEO
and a great board, a direct director of the board. And, uh,
anyway, so they're going to be on our On our work
session in the next meeting, so I'll let them speak at that moment. But the
Youth Council met with them as well. We're gonna probably have some changes coming
down the pipe for some, we're gonna adjust some of the
code for them. On which one? The Youth Council. The Youth Council.
And I won't go over all of them, but one of them, for instance,
is we're actually removing 7th graders from it and only making it 8th through 12th.
And just some other changes. But I've already been coordinating
with Natalie on that to get that cycled back, so. Okay,
Lacey, did you hear that? Make sure you add a note for the work session.
So just a— I just wanna ask some questions actually.
This is— I don't know if Brad's still on. Brad Hickman.
Hickman. Is he still on with us? No? So Ben, I'll maybe
just hand this to you. I wanna make sure that we're making all of the
things available available for the preparation of the rodeo grounds. So this isn't
a last-minute decision. There's a lot of preparation that needs to take place,
so they need to have the tractor over there to make sure that we're getting
the, the ground tilled up.
We also probably need to, to do what we can to help prevent
the contamination of dirt by other materials being
dropped on the rodeo grounds. So there's a special material
that they bring in for that. So we need to make sure that we're not
combining. Um, and then, um, I just want
to make sure that we're doing everything we can to help, uh, the Pony Express
events that puts on our rodeo for us, that they have the things that they
need, uh, where we're not scrambling at the last minute.
Uh, and then the last thing with that is the volunteers for that.
I would love for us to take a more active role as a city in
helping to facilitate getting volunteers for that, but that burden is not
placed solely on the company that's putting on the rodeo for us.
Community Services Board is meeting tomorrow, and they are
well on their way. Jesse Southworth,
our chair, president,
CEO of the committee,
she's building this awesome website. where citizens
can go and put where trails should be? App.
Oh, it's an app. Sorry, app. Android's coming soon. It's awesome.
Within like a week of her presidency,
she's moving. And the committee's doing a great job. I also
just wanted to report real quick on— we met with Ace Disposal today,
Councilmember Wood and myself and Ben.
I appreciate Ben putting this together. Just to explore the idea
of doing bulk curbside waste.
So we're currently looking into 2 different options. One would
allow for bulk waste either on a monthly or quarterly cadence
where people could put a fridge, a dresser, any heavy items
out on their curb and they would drive through the city, pick it up,
and haul it off. And then we're also looking at a dumpster program where dumpsters
can be rented for neighborhoods at $50 to
$100 cost per neighborhood to just rent the dumpster and fill it up.
So also, third option would be even on an individual
basis. So if you had to clear out your entire lot, that would be available
for you to rent. We're looking at all 3 of those options.
Okay, is there anything else on that?
Any— we've kind of covered the liaison reports. Any communication
items coming up? We're still trying to schedule some meetings and stuff, right? So I
think we've covered all that. If that's all of it, then open for a motion.
Motion to adjourn. Second. Okay, we have a motion
to adjourn by Councilmember Clark, a second by Councilmember Whiting. All in favor?
Aye. Aye. Any opposed? Seeing none, we are adjourned at 9:05.
What did he say before we went? What was the last thing that Zach
said? First and foremost— Garbage.